good morning
um
welcome to edna
i'd be opening the public hearing in
senate bill 325 and i will call senator
kavanagh who's the prime sponsor
who will give us a pink card after he's
through
ah
this the senate does things differently
we all know that
senator
thank you madam chair and committee
members for letting me testify my name
is kevin cavanaugh representing senate
district 16.
the towns of beau candia dunbarton
hooksett and manchester wards 1 2 and
12.
i brought this bill forward um to
declare emergency personnel including
local organizations for emergency
management
the department of public works employees
worked through
so much of the shutdown they kept our
cities and towns running
um there's so many groups that were
there that
originally we had this language to add
them to define as first responses to get
into new hampshire law religion
originally we had the language that we
matched from the homeland security act
of 2002
we did work with the state fire marshal
and the emergency management director is
here today to take any questions uh to
place that in the right spot in statute
and we did work on that where it's gonna
if if you see fit is to keep that where
we did place it to um
to put in an appropriate spot is that we
worked with together to do that but we
did we had dpw workers running the towns
we had mechanics and water work
professionals throughout the state that
were on the front line managing repairs
during our shutdown
another group that really did an
exception exceptional job was they're
public health professionals they were
working seven days a week and i know in
manchester they started the first
drive-through testing uh in the state if
not the country and it's just i think
it's just an important way to to
show these employees what they've done
did for us and what they continue to do
and that's why i put in the bill and
would be glad to take any any questions
but i know there's a lot of people
behind me experts in the field
working people and people that are
running the department of public works
so thank you very much madam chair and
committee members
thank you senator i have a question
other than the honor and glory what does
this do to first responders
is there any practical impact well i
would like to give that to them a lot of
that is in the emergency management part
of it the the coordination of of um
storm damage a declaration of uh
emergency over a typical one not that we
saw on a pandemic but more the
communication of a storm damage or
something where you're getting all the
parties together
to communicate thank you very much
are there other questions representative
pearson
thank you madam chair i was uh
i was one of the guys that worked that
drive through
right testing location
um did you
and this may just be because it's
already in statute this way but on line
five the part that says repealed has
that was that repealed a long time ago
was that being repealed as part of this
uh could you repeat where that was a
long time ago
okay
i think we already have the i think i
got the answer apparently it was
repealed a while ago okay we love to we
love to in the past not adjust
numbers and paragraph letters and things
for some reason um so my other question
is then
on the new
[Music]
section which would be i guess nine
starting on line 26
and specifically on line 30 it starts to
mention equipment operators
when you say equipment operators are you
you're referring to public works i would
presume since it follows the the public
works and other skilled support
personnel
correct public works waterworks
mike
it is
is it your intention
and i i'm concerned about this being a
something like an unattended consequence
is your intention for them at some point
to come before this committee and ask to
be placed into group two absolutely not
that's one of the
first things that came up and i have no
intention of that i don't think we
should i think that's um they're built
into where they are where their pension
funds are and i i
my intention is not to allow that at all
okay
thank you for
making sure that's on the record and
also i want to thank you for that drive
through uh testing too my wife was there
too at the time was working for
manchester water and mitch's the health
department she's no longer there but you
guys did an incredible job there were
long hours and a lot of people coming
through at a time when we didn't have a
vaccine and we didn't know how deadly
this was so thank you we fought each
other over who was going to be testing
the aldermen by the way
[Laughter]
you won i guess
representative o'brien has a question
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking my question uh basically am i
correct in assuming
that this already exists in the incident
command structure within what is adopted
with most fire and police in this
particular state
so in the in it's in the command
structure if something was needed from
public works or something like that they
would come in so what this clearly is
the intent of this is to give it
legitimate authority that they are
included as first responders to deal
let's say in the example of a flood
situation where uh slush gate did not
operate the neighborhood's being flooded
the fire department is the lead
organization but would seek to help a
public works to help alleviate that so
i'd be correct in assuming that you
would be and that's what we did work
with the state fire marshal and the
emergency management director we do not
want to intend this to change the
structure we want to keep the structure
the way it is but add those um
dpw workers water works health care
worker health department workers on that
um but not
it was very
it was good work to work with those two
groups to say we in no way want to
change the command
structure
okay
thank you senator are there other
questions
all right seeing none i call
representative edgar
thank you
the state's
for the record my name is mike edgar i
represent hampton
and
i want to thank the madam chairman and
the committee members for allowing me to
speak to you today concerning sb 325 i'm
here
to speak in favor of it
the bill amends rsa21-p
colon 35
which addresses local organizations for
emergency management it modifies some
definitions and inserts the following
definition of first responders into the
rsa
first responders means state county and
local government and non-governmental
emergency public safety fire law
enforcement public safety
telecommunications or dispatcher
emergency response emergency medical
service providers including hospital
emergency facilities
emergency management
health public health
clinical care
public works
and other skilled support personnel such
as equipment operators that provide
immediate support services necessary to
perform emergency management functions
okay so that that was added in
this helps to find public works
employees as one of the groups that are
authorized to be designated as emergency
management personnel and first
responders
it is important to recognize and ensure
department of public work employees are
included when emergency responders are
identified in plans
exercises
and implementation to buyerism
bioterrorism attacks terrorism attacks
catastrophic or natural disasters and
emergencies
many times public russian employees are
the very first on the scene
semi likened it to the world war ii u.s
navy seabees which cleared the
obstructions for landing crafts so the
u.s marine corps could reach the beach
some people might disagree with that but
i know many would take exception to this
but hope you understand that most times
public works employees are the first on
the scene okay public works personnel
are essential workers critical to the
town of hampton's response to
emergencies and natural disasters
storms including frequent flooding
handling snow and ice
and keeping the roads clear of
obstructions are a few of the
reoccurring events that public works
deals with
if the roads are not safe other
emergency responders are hampered or
prevented from performing their duties
i hope you recognize the important role
of public works personnel perform
during and following emergencies and
natural disasters thanks for considering
the bill and please vote out to pass on
sb 325
thank you representative could you uh
give us a copy of your written remarks
oh yes i have i did already i i passed
them i handed them at the beginning of
me okay thank you very much and i also
handed in
the letter that was written by ira
publix director jennifer hale
that had provided it uh previous to the
uh
to the senate which i think has some
good information in it we do appreciate
that information are there any other
questions
from the committee
okay i don't see any so thank you thank
you very much
ed edmund
thank you madam chairpers
uh again my name is ed emond uh
i have worked at the dpw here in
manchester new hampshire for the past 20
years
i just want to say thank you for all
your time and effort and
attempting to help us and we do need
your help on this we i do
i do um
i
want this bill to pass we do need this
to pass
um and i do appreciate all your time and
effort and help thank you
thank you uh are there any questions
no i guess not thanks thanks for being
so efficient
den harper
good morning everybody my name is jen
harper i'm the director for new
hampshire homeland security and
emergency management and um as senator
cavanaugh said we worked together with
him as well as the state fire marshal
sean toomey to make these changes and i
am here in support of it and
i can answer any questions anybody may
have
thank you very much representative
o'brien and then pearson
um thank you manager and thank you for
taking my question
could there be a hidden benefit with
this and
let's say
public works may be able to seek some
grant funding from the federal
government let's say to improve their
radios for uh interoperability with uh
incident command and
other things in certain type of
emergencies
could that be like one of the potential
benefits that could come up so they can
do that now through the
many grant opportunities that the state
has
but
you never know when grant opportunities
may present themselves so this will help
them
in a disaster to make sure that
they are now but we just want to make
sure that public works is truly
recognized as one of our first
responders in the state and if there is
a disaster that they
are afforded the opportunity for
reimbursement of expenses they are now
but it's just in writing so it
further solidifies that good thank you
thank you madam chair
thank you director harper um
i'm just thinking i have a master's
degree in emergency management so i'm
thinking back to
my time at oklahoma state in the infancy
of this profession and
things have certainly changed and
evolved over time
and you touched a little bit in your
answer with chief o'brien or sorry
representative o'brien as far as
as what
this
some of the things that this could
potentially do
but in reference to what chairman
mcguire said you know other than
some feel-good stuff what is
what does the world look like for you
once this passes what is different
that this bill does that it does that
doesn't happen right now
like you said it's feel good it clearly
recognizes public works as one of new
hampshire's first responders like i said
to representative o'brien
public works and as the gentleman just
spoke is very integral to emergency
response as you all know um
the
public works association that we work
with now
are really great partners
and
we need to get more of the communities
into that association but i think with
this it
clearly defines them as part of the
incident command structure
part of when there is an emergency that
they're in the emergency operations
center
providing data providing information to
make decisions whether it's in hampton
or manchester or concord or wherever
for the incident commanders
responding to whatever flood tornado
whatever um
they've been
[Music]
i'm not going to say left out
but left out of you know being
identified so
i don't know how else to answer your
question
okay so what i'm getting from this is
that this is basically a this will
potentially improve
lines of communication
in the sense of
some of the reimbursements that occur
from the federal government
so
so if we have let me use an example so
we had the july storms out in cheshire
and sullivan county flooding and we got
a presidential disaster declaration for
them
yes
and so
public works as well as new hampshire
d.o.t public works state level
were out there night and day for many
days repairing roads they still are
and the work that they do
will be reimbursed
by fema
reimbursement rate at this point
and
those eligible activities get documented
the work gets done they get reimbursed
so
the communications
the collaboration and the reimbursements
for disaster declarations
all
this enhances that um
it's not a re you know it's not required
by the federal government that we list
every single first responder
it just helps us with our emergency
planning
process and procedures and the plans
that the locals have
perfect thank you
representative
bailey thank you
thank you
several witnesses have spoken in terms
of a command structure that's in place
and not all of the entities listed here
are public
entities and by including them in this
list does that imply that you will
henceforth be able to command them
well you might
you might cooperate with them but no no
no we already do that yeah that's
already
private and public partnerships are very
integral to the incident command
structure and that has existed for a
long time partners don't command yes
they do in this case they do
ah then they're not partners are they
we'll take we'll take this up in private
i think gentlemen
uh i do have one question i'm from a
small town we don't have a public works
department would this would that be
essentially our road agent and his crew
yes yes thank you and hopefully you
belong to the public works mutual aid
assistance group
beyond my scope
all right
representative judy yes good morning
director
um i see and i understand
the homeland security
but i would like to know if we don't put
why we don't put national guards
in that emergency the national guard the
national guard is a as a state partner
with us in the emergency operations
center
yep so they are when we activate the
state emergency operations center for
disaster
uh they are a partner with us they do a
lot of logistics for us
yep they were integral in the covid
response you probably saw them um
staffing the tents and the vaccine
clinics and
yeah so they are
a support partner with us okay all right
thank you yep
other questions
all right thank you yes representative
o'brien excuse me uh thank you madam
chair uh
your comment uh kind of got me so my
question to you
uh in nashua we're pretty prepared we're
very fortunate to have our own emergency
preparedness director
but
the chairman chairwoman brought up a
very good point some communities cannot
or do not you know have an emergency
preparedness so this is up makes it
an enlightenment in a way that they can
now think of this to extend within the
incident command system so this will
definitely help where no thought was
previously thought to a road agent or
something like that that he is part of
this right emergency preparedness
sustainability so i know we use the word
public works but that also equates back
to what representative mcguire said to
your road agent same
synonymous well not exactly but very
close yes
all right thank you other questions
all right thank you very much
tim uh clarity
good morning madam chair and the rest of
the committee members
my name is tim clardy i'm
the deputy public works director for the
city of manchester and i also serve as a
president of the new hampshire public
works association
i'm here representing uh all of its
membership as well as the 61 cities and
towns that are members of the new
hampshire public works association
i'm here today to encourage your support
of sb 325 the term first responder
refers to those individuals
who in the early stages of an incident
are responsible for the protection and
preservation
of life property and the environment
these emergency
response providers include emergency
management
public health clinical care
public works and other skilled support
personnel such as equipment operators
that provide immediate support services
during prevention response and recovery
operations
it's our hope that this legislation
which defines a span of local control
during emergency
can be established at the state level
recognizing the important role of
emergency
emergency management personnel including
public works
during times of major and minor
disasters
and by formally recognizing
their role as first responders
within the state of new hampshire as
it's already been done by the federal
government
uh just a couple other comments you know
i i appreciate all the questions i
appreciate this the support of senator
senator cavanaugh for bringing this
legislation forward representative edgar
and the comments from director harper
and ed emond
as well as the questions from the
committee
i can tell you that as as a president of
new hampshire public works association
there is no hidden agenda with any of
the legislation that you see before you
this is simply formally codifying the
role that public works plays during
disasters and emergencies as you've
heard
all the people before me testifying to
and this formally recognizes that i
thank you for your service to the state
and allow me the time to address the
committee
thank you are there any questions
oh thank
seeing none very very good thank you
meghan terrio
good morning
my name is megan terrio and i am the
guilford public works director and i
have proudly served the public works
community for 18 years i'm here today to
express my full support for sb 325 which
will recognize public works employees as
emergency management personnel and first
responders
dpw employees perform numerous critical
services during extreme weather events
the pandemic and other emergencies that
impact communities all over new
hampshire
many of the emergency services we offer
are often taken for granted because they
occur on such a regular basis that
people don't think of what daily life
would be like without them
one of the most well-known emergency
services that we provide are winter
operations which include snow plowing
and treatment on roads dpws are on call
24 7 to provide those emergency services
during snowstorms and without dpw first
responders travel on roads could quickly
become impassable for the public
including police and fire departments
trying to respond to their own emergency
calls
accidents would increase exponentially
and so would the burden on police and
fire departments to those accident
scenes without the emergency services
provided by dpw
other weather-related emergencies that
dpw first responders
respond to which are less common but can
significantly impact travel on roads are
flooding events wind storms and ice
storms
during these events many roads need to
be temporarily shut down due to varying
hazards and dpw's on-call 24 7 to
provide emergency services such as
unclogging drainage pipes and structures
removing trees and limbs from the travel
ways placement of barricades and signage
and traffic control is needed
even after intense rain and flooding
events are over there are often weeks
that dpw is involved in the cleanup and
repair of the washouts and opening up
pipes and structures replacing failed
pipes before all the roads can be
reopened in a community without these
emergency services by dpw the public
would be at a high risk for traveling on
countless unsafe roads and police and
fire response could be negatively
impacted
another very important but often
overlooked critical service provided by
dpw personnel is solid waste management
in the operation of water and sewer
systems
during the pandemic collecting municipal
solid waste and maintaining a functional
water and sewer system became an
immediate essential service that could
not shut down
dpws who were short staffed due the
pandemic had to shift employees around
to provide critical coverage at each of
these divisions
to ensure not a
to ensure
service without a break
in addition to their essential daily
services the water and sewer staff of
dpw are on call 24 7 to provide
emergency services to respond to system
and pump alarms water main breaks sewer
main backups and without immediate
response by dpw first responders a
community could be impacted by a major
health or safety issue
unsafe drinking water environmental
violations to lakes or streams and major
roadway damage or failure from a water
main break
these are just some of the most common
instances where dpw is a key member of a
town or city's emergency management
personnel
dpw's work hand in hand with police and
fire whenever called upon for emergency
services needed in a community
i encourage all of you to support sb 325
and recognize public works employees as
the first responders they already are
and will continue to be with or without
the recognition that they deserve in
this legislation
thank you to the supporters of this bill
and for everyone's time today and
allowing me to speak
thank you miss terrio uh we'll ask you
for a copy of your testimony if you can
share it
any other questions from the committee
all right seeing none thank you very
much
is there any other member of the public
who wishes to testify on senate bill 325
all right seeing none i will close the
hearing
and we have two minutes
if anyone's
who spoke from a written testimony would
like to present that to me that will be
i can put it in the file
two minutes
it was
yes thank you so much i appreciate it
yesterday
thank you for coming today what's up
this one sounds like a relatively
harmless way to be nice to people that's
not a big deal
good how are you
and
like the people couldn't get back to
their homes
and there was
glad you could make it you're busy
will you have a seat what are you doing
he's the man
he's delivering he's delivering the mail
thank you we've got we've got these
already
actually we don't want it give it to uh
i've got a 28-day issue with this
all right
all right it
being 10 30 i'm opening the hearing on
senate bill 357 and i call senator
birdsell
thank you
madam chair thank you committee for
hearing
350 senate bill 357
of which i am the prime sponsor for the
record my name is regina bartzel i am
the state senator for district 19 which
encompasses the towns of derry hampstead
and windham
and
senate bill 357
i also sit as chair of the commission on
ptsd so what this bill does we decided
to do a little bit of
start a little early and
reconstitute the commission on ptsd for
first responders so this
allows us to continue our work come
november when the commit commission
ends it also requires and this was a
bill that was put in last year and got
taken out during the omnibus
debacles i'll say
so it requires
first responders to be trained in ptsd
and
fire right now firefighters and
police officers are required to have
when they're going through their
training before they take on a job when
they're going through the police academy
or the fire academy it requires them to
be trained in p um in ptsd as well as an
annual online training one of the things
that we found in the commission was
there and this is all levels of fire and
and police what we found in the
commission is it's really needs a
culture change
and the culture is actually changing to
address ptsd
but i think this this will help
allow the leadership in the fire and the
police to understand ptsd and it also
allows
the young
police officers and firefighters coming
up through to understand that there is
ptsd
attached to some of these
these jobs that they do
so with that i'll try and
answer any questions
good morning senator i have one question
i noticed the fiscal note mentions an
impact on
local communities
it should not impact local communities
because as firefighters go through the
fire academy this is going to be a
training
yes but
we have currently have
firefighters and police officers
who have not yet gone through that train
and i'm sure other towns and cities are
in the same situation are you only
making it available
and requiring new officers to be trained
or are you expecting to go back and
train every existing fire firefighter or
police officer no the intent is just
new ones coming up but
everyone will be required to do an
online training which is actually no
cost
from what i've heard is it cost
online training is actually no cost nami
is also going to help provide with that
okay
so i will uh
so i think we will need to make very s
very clear
that it is
no effort is required on the part of
current
officers and first responders other than
taking the online training
thank you thank you does anyone else
have a question
representative schmidt
thank you madam chairman good morning
senator
so this is a quite a
large commission
uh uh have you already been in contact
with
all the constituent organizations
with regard to their
abilities and or willingness to
participate
yes we have the chief
as you can see the the membership on the
commission is probably quite broad we
actually opened it up to
the commissioner of corrections as well
so the chief the
chief of police association is a member
the
members of nashua manchester police the
firefighters
professional firefighters of new
hampshire are members and they they all
agree that this is really needed
okay thank you
are there other questions
all right
thank you thank you senator
thank you
david goldstein
now i am
thank you
i still have a flip phone so
good morning
madam chair members of the committee uh
my name is david goldstein for the
record i'm presently the chief of police
in the city of franklin i've been there
for over 13 years as chief
i've been a police officer for over 42
years
i didn't prepare any specific remarks
for this morning i know that this has
been floating around the legislature for
a while and i wanted to this morning to
speak a little bit both from the head
and the heart
about this matter
you as members of the greatest country
in the world have certain expectations
of the people that are going to care for
you
in a very realistic sense
fire police ems corrections
we have every right in the world
to leave your house any time of the day
or night and feel safe
and our job is to make sure that that is
guaranteed
what people don't know is how the
sausage is made
and quite frankly it's a very difficult
process for those who are involved in it
and i'm certainly happy to answer
questions about that
i live in what's called the contingency
what i call a contingency world
that's a what-if world
what if this what if that
and i spend my day making decisions
relative to that as do my offices and as
do the rest of the first responders in
the state of new hampshire
why
we have a front row seat to despair on a
daily basis
we prepare for battle every single day
people don't dress like this normally
and i don't even have my body hammer on
because i don't need it hopefully for
today
we ride an emotional roller coaster
some days are good some days are bad i
save a life today i take one tomorrow
and then there's often negative public
perception for virtually everything that
a first responder does at any time
because people know better than we do
because they watch television and movies
the problem with that is that's
two-dimensional
my world is three-dimensional
madam chair you made a comment uh i just
want to address and perhaps correct just
a little bit i've been teaching at the
new hampshire police academy since 1981
and the topic that i teach for the
recruits is mitigating and dealing with
stress crisis and trauma in that
particular area
i've taught about ptsd
since the dsm-2 was in vogue it's now
the dsm-5
so yes we do have a basic
knowledge of what that entails and we've
talked about it a lot
i think that the most important thing
today quite frankly i'm very socratic in
nature especially when i teach at the
college level
and that is questions and answers so
with that i'm going to end my testimony
and ask if there are any questions from
the group
thank you
thank you representative rhodes
thank you madam chair
good morning chief thank you for taking
my question my pleasure so um
i'm i just have a question about the
the annual so that you go to the
training
and the annual training and one of the
i don't have a concern with having the
training i'm just curious if if maybe a
a bi-annual wouldn't be
my concern is with the lack of
officers that we're hearing there's a
lack of first responders all the way
around and you know
obviously i'm assuming you'd probably
stagger this but what would happen if a
person's you know their year is up and
they haven't gone to the training yet
you know
what exactly would be the role there
would it be when you just can't go until
you've had this training or is there
going to be like a little bit of elapsed
time in there should it be maybe
bi-annually just to kind of i can't
really imagine it's going to change that
much in a year
as far as the updates
representative pearson's giving me dirty
looks from behind you
not me
no are you talking about uh people that
are already on duty and in the system
themselves
yes i'm i'm looking at the page three
it's actually on on line 10 where it
says the subsequent initial training and
then
um that you have to complete
my understanding from this would be
annually after that like like continue
like continuing ed i would think is that
the understanding yes um
if we're going to be professional like
any other profession law medicine etc we
have to have ongoing education
and we do do that and being familiar
with how the academy works and how they
develop classes and try to stay up to
date with things like this absolutely
this is done we also have on ground
training uh that's often what we call
in-service and we do that advanced
classes on stress management crisis
trauma for both line offices supervisors
and for chiefs of police or command
personnel so yeah there's there's
nothing that would preclude us from
being able to do this i do this all the
time in my department if something new
comes down that's necessary and it's
online
what my full expectation is the officer
is going to sit down at his or her
computer
and take the class and and go from there
hopefully that helps address your
question so to do it annually would not
be a large a large problem
so so it's your understanding that
once the course is developed it would be
available for all the officers in the
state to take at their convenience sure
yes
which makes sense i have a question i
would like to add
after this is
like at the bottom of page one
to say that
current law enforcement officers are
encouraged to attend such training
programs but are only required to
successfully complete the annual online
training
to make it clear that we are not
imposing a mandate on the towns that
aren't perhaps not as well organized as
yours
that would that be the
would that clarify your intention on
this that they're encouraged to attend
but it's not a not a mandate that they
sign up for a major course
i i
would prefer a mandate
personally uh and it doesn't cost me any
extra money to do that
if i've got an officer who's on duty and
he he or she needs to take an hour off
to do a course we do that now with a
variety of things right so
i don't see that as as interfering or
becoming a female i meant that
you said you have on ground training and
things like yes
yes so i would say that someone who's
been a police officer
well you started in 81 so that's that's
a long time ago
actually started in 79 but that's a
whole nother story
round right okay so
um
we'll we'll talk about that because i'm
i'm i'm concerned about
people who are
who have had some formal training in the
past
and now that they don't want to think
that they're now required to take a
week's course at the police standards
and training or whatever it wouldn't be
a week's course anyway and and i'd
certainly be happy to discuss it further
okay thank you that's just my concern
representative o'brien
thank you um along that vein though
uh from people i know
that have suffered with this and you
know i come from the firefighting ranks
ptsd is an insidious disease or
affliction uh a lot of people have it
that realize that they don't have it
right because of the counterculture of
the
police or fire i mean
you know scraping the body off the floor
that's part of what we do
and it may affect you
and may it not affect you
you never know when it's going to hit so
mandatory
is the key here to really get the people
in because they're not going to show you
any outside signs until they're drunk or
maybe committing suicide
i can't disagree with that i've been i'm
a member of two critical instant stress
management teams so certainly i see this
and my own career the things i've had to
do and be involved in certainly i agree
with you
the statistics are staggering for all
first responders
as to how many of us are actually
walking around with ptsd
clinically speaking the uh however
behind that is the fact that the
american psychiatric association updates
their diagnostic and statistical manual
every five to seven years and the
criteria may change so we have to be
aware of that as well
if that happens no other questions
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair good morning chief
good morning good to see you again
always um
we had another bill a couple of days ago
where we had a number of
police officers and corrections
officers before us and
that the testimony
in general quite
uh
quite uh
shattering is probably too strong a word
but but really quite emotionally uh
devastating for me hearing the kinds of
things that uh these police officers
have experienced on a virtually daily
basis dead children for example uh
uh
one can imagine all kinds of
circumstances in which death suddenly
is thrust upon an uns suspecting person
of any age
but but a dead child is always a special
tragedy uh but but i don't think i even
though i could theorize about it uh
i don't think i'd ever really heard that
kind of testimony before
we know that combat veterans for example
very often don't talk about their
experiences in combat at all
i i served in the lower but never saw
combat
uh
your question
madam chair there's always a question
sometimes it has to be framed a little
bit the chief was not here for that
particular hearing that's why i let you
introduce it yeah i'm sure he can
easily imagine
the kinds of things i'm talking about
but but
the the
mental strain that police officers and
firefighters emergency responders of all
kinds i can be subjected to
suddenly or routinely
has got to be a matter of tremendous
concern to their families as well
so
uh
this this
mental health training
for first responders what are we doing
for the family members especially
spouses
uh who see their their their loved one
uh you know coming back after a
difficult experience but they they're
impacted as well what are we doing for
them
nothing in this bill i'm sorry nothing
in this bill addresses that correct
that's correct correct well yes but
we're do we
we're developing expertise you've been
doing this for over 40 years quickly
doing the math uh it was an easy one
with the years you gave
uh so you you're developing expertise
what what how we can we make that
available to family members
that's a very good question
representative and um
it's a little bit of a complex answer so
i'm going to just take a couple moments
to to address that
similar to what uh representative
o'brien was saying uh the attitude used
to be suck it up buttercup
and if you can't take it find another
job it was that simple in the old days
uh i actually began this work in the
mid-1970s
before i ever became a police officer
when i was in graduate school doing some
clinical work
and then i became a police officer and
carried that over
so what we try to do is early on in the
academy when when i get these
individuals for a grand total of four
hours
i try to include the issues dealing with
family
as best that i can
in the in service training the on ground
in service training we tried to do that
as well what i have found over the years
is as this has become more of a cause
celeb and we understand more about this
um
and we conduct what are known as
critical instance stress debriefings
after an issue like that for example
which is a relatively new
uh it's been around for a while but the
the enactment of that is relatively new
we spend a lot of time in those
debriefings talking to the individuals
involved about how their families are
going to be affected
the reality is we hope that the message
gets home
one way or another
there is no bill there is no statute
there is no rule that requires families
be involved uh and quite frankly some of
my colleagues and i'm sure some of fire
and ems are the same way they go home
how was your day dear no big deal
until the uh until the plastic trash
barrel in the kitchen goes flying by you
your your significant other's right ear
and then say hmm bad day type of thing
so this is something that we still need
to work on we have been doing that i
will say that
um and i can certainly identify with
some of what you said my youngest i was
a homicide detective i was major crime
but state police my 23 year uh 23-year
career state police for about a dozen
years my youngest victim was 10 weeks
old here in concord so
who was murdered so along with her
sisters and her mother so i understand
exactly what you're saying and this is
the stuff that we have to work on i wish
i had a very definitive answer for you
and i appreciate the preamble that you
gave but it's the best i got for the
moment
thank you very much
are there any other questions
representative judy
good morning chief good morning
nice to see you again oh
uh did uh police officers
in the past
uh the academy did the the they have the
training mental health training yes
on a variety of levels nami for example
has a course of study as well within the
class so it's not just mine there are
other uh there are other
classes within the academy regimen
itself that cover mental health issues
too
so i just don't want you to think it's
just mine there are others but i do have
them
yes okay
thank you are there other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
representative pearson
thank you for the record representative
pearson rockingham district six dairy
i just i sit on the ptsd commission
right now and i just wanted to address a
couple of things that i've heard um
representative schmidt you talked about
the the
size and scope of the commission the
commission already exists these
positions are already filled and there's
already people doing them
the commission is extraordinarily active
and meets monthly and it's working and
the agencies seem to be fine with
with
their role in the commission
as far as family members go
there's nothing in state statute that
dictates family members but one of the
things that
some of the communities have done upon
themselves especially the city of
manchester has is to provide
some of that awareness training to
family members and we've done that
three times in the city of manchester in
the last two years so that's not really
a state requirement but some communities
are
bringing that upon themselves to do that
and that's certainly their their choice
um
if if you're looking to expand that
i would i would say that you know we
gotta walk before we run
and this is this is the walk so
um but i do appreciate your recognition
of that because it is not just a single
person event this definitely affects
folks in your family
so you know part of the part of the
reason why that i'm on the commission
it's near and dear to me is i've had two
working partners that have committed
suicide
which is
unheard of um
and that is something that i don't want
to see
i certainly don't want a third but i
certainly don't want to see this
situation and these problems exacerbate
themselves and keep going when we have
the ability to do some intervention here
as far as annual training i would i'd
like to to bring up that we
have annual sexual harassment training
for employees i mean those there are
certain things that
that are worthy of touching upon an
annual basis and i'll tell you
pushing something like this out to a
two-year venue there's a lot of bad
things that happen in the course of a
year for someone and
you know the this the type of training
that's being looked at right now i can
tell you from the fired up
standpoint the new hampshire fire
academy is focused in developing and
expanding upon the online training they
have now and once the fire academy
creates this training
it's going to be available for fire
departments throughout the state
regardless of status whether they're
paid a career volunteer or whatever
and that's just a matter of sitting down
on a computer and watching a program so
you know as far as as far as this
becoming some sort of a mandate that
comes down upon communities to have to
fork over all kinds of money that just
isn't there with the state's
handling this is is part of their
function and making this available so so
this isn't going to be a 28a issue or
anything like that we're not going to be
dumping
all sorts of things that are going to
require and frankly if if that
if that if we'd been going down that
road we would have been i would have
intervened in that a long long before
this because that's
obviously not going to work so so this
the way 357 is written
right now um you know the the beginning
of this obviously is just the
reconstitution of the com the commission
but the bottom part here i think that
you know as senator birdsell said you
know we are in desperate need of a
cultural shift and it has begun
um but it without
continuing to reinforce that cultural
shift it's going to take a generation or
two for that to really set in
so
other than that i have i'm happy to take
questions at least from the fire
standpoint or my own personal experience
thank you
representative i have two questions
one is that i'm
fully supportive of adding this to the
continuing education requirement and if
it's online yes that's free i'm
concerned
that it
we
i want to make it clear that we're not
asking
current
firefighters or police officers to go
back to the academy for the
sa mental health training etc from so
that's
that doesn't
yes new people ought to take it no
question
but we shouldn't end with it should be
available to other people but i don't
think we should mandate that every
experienced police or firefighter in the
state go through that
uh so that's that's my concern the other
is why are you reconstituting the
committee instead of just repealing its
end date
i mean that would be the
it seems to me that would be a much
simpler way to do it if you're happy if
the commission exists subsequently that
would have the same effect i suppose
okay so i as far as i i can tell from
reading this there's no change in the
makeup of the commission right i mean
it's the same
oh
so there is an update to the topics
okay
fine so
thank you sure are there any other
questions representative o'brien
thank you uh madam chair i look forward
hopefully we could talk about this but
again
uh
representative pearson thank you for
taking my question but and through your
experience on this particular board and
everything ptsd
it could be as acute as one particular
incident but it also has a cumulative
effect equally as well
it could be things going on at home the
wife leaving
the job stinks you know other different
things i get skipped over promotion
oh there was a bad car accident one
involved a kid other different things
let's go out and have a little drink
i'll feel a little bit better
other things and lead and you're on the
slippery sloping too and usually these
aren't people who are just coming out of
the academy they're equally to be people
that may have 15 years of service
uh that we may need to reach out to so
it uh
we just can't say that it's uh
what is the trigger point we don't know
what that triangle point is it can
affect anybody at any particular point
within their career or it'd be
correct and assuming that
well absolutely the the other thing too
that we're touching on along with your
own internal diagnosis of of your
particular situation is the recognition
amongst your peers of of things that are
warning signs
and that
you know
as they say you can lead a horse to
water but in this particular case you
know one of the things that
has in the past has been difficult is no
one knew where to lead the horse right
okay so
part of what this commission does has
done is is
making that avenue a lot more clear and
available for those that once they do
recognize they have a situation we can
get them to
the appropriate
intervention if you will the appropriate
remedy the appropriate counseling
whatever it takes um you know because
frankly in the past that was
we you know we had some some teams in
the state but we didn't it wasn't really
broad
it was too broad in the sense of you
know if you asked a volunteer fire chief
you got a guy in trouble where do you
send him a lot of you got the
firefighter salute from a lot of them
they just didn't know so
that's something that the commission has
also worked on and
um and i in is ongoing you know as we're
as we're having a certain shortage of
mental health practitioners in this
state as we heard in reference to that
an interstate compact in another bill
but
um you know this is this is an
all-encompassing commission it's looking
at it from you know from cradle to grave
and
and uh
and i think
i mean your your analysis of that is
correct but
but i want to assure you that that
part of it is absolutely addressed in
this
follow up if i may madam champ follow
representative schmidt schmidt did
mention
families and everything and
has it been your experience you know
firefighting police officers it is a
family orientated we all know
everybody's kids
you know
things that are going on sometimes we
know things before even the spouses do
you know
but sometimes chiefs do get the call or
the union may get the call or you know
reach out to friends within the
department that murphy's having a
particular problem or something like
that so
families are an integral part but they
are included and they are listened to so
yep one of the things that that occurred
within the the training that the city of
manchester did was in reference
with the family members and their
avenues of intervention
you know because of course we all sit
down and take these trainings and we're
given the
you know who do you call and what do you
do and who do you talk to and this is
the resources available
but that's been
that's been very absent in the in the
family member world so the the training
that the city of manchester put on did
just that
for folks that were that had taken it it
gave them hey this is the resources
here's who you can call
you know this is this is what you can do
and again this is not touched in this
bill and and i don't
i think like i said we need to walk
before we run but but in the future that
is something that could be looked at i
carefully
any other questions
thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 357
all right
seeing none
i will close the public hearing
all right welcome back
i'm opening the hearing on senate bill
uh senator ricciardi is not here
representative o'brien could you
introduce yourself
wasn't that what i said
that's okay as long as we're on the same
page
it is 383 relative to land survey
thank you madam chair and good morning
to my fellow committee members
it is my pleasure introducing you this
morning is uh senate bill 383 relative
relative to land surveying services
this bills provides a land surveying
non-resident licensure and civil
penalties foreign licensed land surveyor
practices and i'm sure there's other
good qualified people behind me that can
explain this further thank you
thank you representative
mark
kind of from a trophy
thank you very much i just have a brief
statement and then i'm happy to answer
any questions that the committee has
regarding this legislation and
information so
my name is mark condodemitraki and i am
the government affairs director for the
new hampshire land surveyors association
i'm here to testify in favor of and
offer my support
i i can
if you don't mind sir that would be
polite absolutely
senator we had the bill introduced on
your behalf but we'd love to hear from
you
i think we're still mourning aren't we
yes good morning everyone
give me just a moment
good morning madam chair members of the
house the edna committee i'm senator
denise ricciardi representing district
9.
today i am introducing
senate bill 383
relative to land surveying services
the bill before you was amended by the
senate and it aims to accomplish two
things
to begin with my legislation deals with
a private cause of action
as we know the attorney general is
responsible for enforcing the laws of
the state
unfortunately we also know that at times
they are overwhelmed with cases
our bill provides for a civil money
penalty or monetary enforcement
that can be levied onto unlicensed
practitioners that hold themselves out
as licensed or adverse services they may
be licensed for
this would allow for significant
consumer protection and allow for the
enforcement of current statutes
this protects new hampshire property
owners and consumers from unlicensed
individuals that are currently offering
low-cost services that ultimately are
not what the client believes them to be
secondly my bill looks at the issue of
non-resident licensure
the new england region is very small an
area and there are several instances
where a person may live in vermont
massachusetts or maine
this could be a significant hindrance to
the individual the company they work for
and the profession as a whole due to
limiting of an already small pool of
potential land surveyors if we want this
profession to grow and thrive we must
look to the next generation of surveyors
that may be willing to commute across
state lines in order to obtain
opportunities this change will make it
easier for land surveyors
in neighboring states
to more easily attain a new hampshire
license as long as the applicant meets
the requirements for licensure as set
forth in our statutes
after consulting with the new hampshire
land surveyor association we discovered
the need for some cleanup language that
was not addressed in the original or
amended bill so an amendment will be
provided to the committee for your
consideration dealing with those changes
i am happy to try to answer any
questions
on the underlying bill but in the
essence of saving time and going back to
committee i have experts behind me that
could probably
be more helpful and i really thank you
for your time and consideration on this
bill
thank you senator are there any specific
questions to the senator
representative rhodes
thank you
madam chairman thank you for taking my
question senator
so i'm just curious um
in the event that a person
is
has a has a
a fine
put on to them and they
do not pay this fine what what exactly
would be the consequence of that would
it be like a lien or
like what exactly would happen i'm gonna
defer to the experts for that for this i
presented this bill on behalf of the
land surveyors
um
thank you thank you
all right i think that
that
exhausts our questions thank you senator
thank you sorry i have to run oh it's
it's a busy morning
you'll probably be getting all the
questions
the first question is going to be can
you go over your last name again and
spell it
if you actually have a you have a if you
have some written testimony we would
appreciate it
i'm sure that will have your name in
in all its glory so
i did um i did email the written
testimony this morning to the committee
so you have a copy and i'm happy to
provide a written copy to the committee
as soon as i'm done reading it as well
um so the connect correct pronunciation
is
uh it's correct just as it is it sounds
it's phonetic it's condodemetraki so
um
so
uh so my name is mark conor demataraki
and i am the government affairs director
of the new hampshire land surveyors
association i'm here to testify in favor
of and offer my support for the
legislation that's in front of this
committee today specifically senate bill
real estate is one of the main drivers
of the new hampshire economy and
surveying is extremely as an extremely
important aspect and really the backbone
of the real estate transaction
whether it's determining property
boundaries and verifying title for the
real estate transfer and transaction to
determining areas of parcels for the
levying of taxes and everything in
between
surveying is a major aspect of the new
hampshire real estate economy
this bill is incredibly important to
many stakeholders in the real estate
industry from realtors lenders property
owners
and especially the courts
unlicensed practice occurs often and in
many cases with disastrous results that
can create significant financial
hardships for property owners
this is why the violations and penalties
aspect of this bill is needed
as stated previously surveying plays a
significant part in the real estate
economy
due to technology and overburdening of
the enforcing party
there are currently many instances where
companies and individuals hold
themselves out as professionals and
perform or advertise work illegally
the loser in this in this scenario is
not only the consumer and other
stakeholders i mentioned but the new
hampshire court system and the budget as
a whole
as its judges that are tasked with
making property and boundary decisions
as our society is becoming more
confrontational we will see our court
system overburdened with the errors of
unprofessional and unlicensed work
this legislation will allow the board to
hold a fair hearing and levy a monetary
fine to deter this kind of work from
being performed
several recent examples of unlicensed
work include a contractor who was
setting property corners in guilford new
hampshire
the property owner that engaged the
contractor was very happy to pay a
reduced fee
for this service
however
there are always
two parties involved in one property
line
and when the neighbor thought that there
was an issue they hired a surveyor
the property corners that did have
surveying caps on them
were found to be set in the wrong
location
this issue was resolved between the two
neighbors
there was cost that occurred between the
two
however this could have created
significant damages between both parties
another example is a homeowner who hired
a contractor to set an elevation
benchmark
in order to build a new home in
compliance with the town floodplain
management ordinance the contractor held
themselves out and communicated to the
client
that they could perform survey quality
work
unfortunately the elevation benchmark
that was set was 13 inches lower than
what was reported due to an error
the homeowner
their house is now out of compliance
with the floodplain management ordinance
for this town
and they're looking at tens of thousands
of dollars
in flood insurance
requirements that they
weren't
expecting to pay
there are multiple companies
advertising in new hampshire on the
internet
stating on their website that they are
professional land surveyors by state
agency
when in fact they hold no license or
credentials
there are also multiple examples where
contractors have altered existing plans
that are on file in town offices that
have the potential to create major
hardships for all the parties involved
i cannot stress how important this
legislation is to the consumers and the
property owners of new hampshire
the second aspect of this legislation is
the elimination of the residency
requirement for initial licensure as a
survey in new hampshire
as the world and our region is growing
smaller so too is the pool of candidates
that are looking to enter the surveying
field
there are many instances where a
potential candidate for licensure may
live in massachusetts maine or vermont
but practices for a firm exclusively in
new hampshire
residency should not be a roadblock to
licensure
and in fact
land surveying is the only profession
that requires residency for initial
licensure
uh physicians engineers attorneys
landscape architects and so on do not
have a residency requirement for initial
licensure
by striking this aspect of the law we
are bringing our profession in line with
the other state licensing requirements
and allowing the board to determine the
eligibility of licensure based on
experience
and not residency
and
i i would like to just reiterate what um
senator rashardi had mentioned about
some of the the technical
corrections on the amendment that she
brought forward for the bill and it just
clarifies certain languages and
corrects some of the technical language
and i'm happy to answer any questions
from the committee
thank you i can see a few
uh but first i don't i don't believe we
actually got senator ricciardi's
amendment
do you have a copy i do have a copy
thank you we will
that will make things simpler madam
chair is this an amendment that was
processed by the senate because this
comes over to us as amended by the
senate is that irrelevant i believe this
senator rashadi said that this came out
after they made their amendment so this
would be something we would want to
do in addition to
i think and i think we may need some
help
so it has something
so this adds yes this adds a dish a
great deal of additional uh
language that's not in the bill before
us
correct correct okay and i have a
general question about land surveying
i was i believe i was told at one time
that the
tracing of deeds in new hampshire is
extremely difficult because of the
pre-colonial era
way it was set up
is the ah you're grinning so you you've
heard that too is is that still the case
that it can be yeah um you know tracing
title and and doing deed research in in
new hampshire and a lot of the colonial
states can be very challenging it's uh
it's a very interesting and rewarding
experience as well
uh
is there a specific new hampshire
legal
legal knowledge
tests that you have to take before being
licensed as a land surveyor yes
absolutely so
and that i think we would want to make
sure is included in the requirements for
out-of-state licensure yes and and it is
it is referenced in that um amendment
that i just
okay thank you we'll check for it and
representative rhodes had a question and
i believe representative o'brien thank
you madam chair
so i don't know if the answer to the
question i had asked the senators in
that amendment
but what exactly
is what would happen when a person says
well i don't have the money
it it responds to the fine thank you
yeah so um
that's a that's a very good question and
uh something that you know would be
referred to the attorney general's
office and uh we would then you know
obviously look for guidance from from
the attorney general
so i just want to make sure my
understanding is of right now if
say i went out and i did this
and the board says you're going to pay
us 5 000 and i say i don't have 5 000
that's just kind of the end of it as of
now no so as of right now let's say you
went out let's say you went out and did
this let's say you decided you were
unlicensed and wanted to go out and
practice surveying or
do surveying work or whatever
and you did the work um currently the
board has no authority over anything
that you're doing um all authority falls
on the shoulders of the attorney general
and you know the attorney general um
their office is
is very overburdened with a lot of you
know civil and criminal matters
whether they would choose to enforce the
law in this situation or not would be up
to their office um one in the one case
that i mentioned in the guilford case
the attorney general's office chose not
to enforce the law in that case
thank you
representative o'brien
thank you thank you madam chair thank
you sir for taking my question i'm
looking at the new section 14 and fifth
line 15 if you have the bill but uh
basically you're asking for uh an
offense of ten thousand dollars for each
offense
and that seems pretty hefty you know
and i'm not against that
uh but on line fourteen it does say uh
in addition to any other penalty
provided by law
uh if somebody's so my question is if
somebody's doing this
and uh on the false pretenses they could
get a ten thousand dollar fine but could
they not in the future void their uh
ability to get a new hampshire license
because they attempted to deceive sure
so the current um
the current enforcement and disciplinary
action that could result in unlicensed
practice is criminal
you would be subject to either a miss it
would be a misdemeanor or a felony
offense and again that would be levied
by you know the attorney general's
office the the state board of licensure
does not have any authority to enforce
you know unlicensed practice against an
unlicensed individual they're
solely tasked with you know disciplining
and overseeing the licensed community
and the people that fall under the
purview of the licensed statute so
currently you know the only enforcement
available in that scenario would be
would be criminal
and then i would presume that if someone
is is applying for a license having been
convicted of unlicensed practice would
be considered
poor character or whatever the
disqualifying event is they would be
considered not not in good standing and
then they would have to you know certify
on the application um as to whether or
not you know they have been you know
arrested or you know have a criminal
record madam sheriff i may i totally
concur what you said because there's a
lot of faith in this you know
particularly for the homeowner to have
it done accurately so you know they
voided that so thank you thank you amen
thank you represent goalie
thank you madam chair and i i just
wanted to follow up with
a comment you made about
the attorney general's office not
following up on some of these things
because they may be too busy or not but
as i look at current statute
on line nine
that any person who shall violate any
other provisions in this subdivision
shall be guilty it doesn't say they may
be
so if the attorney general's not office
isn't
taking these to court and going after
these folks where it's
pretty
specific in statute that they shall be
guilty
um
there's a problem going on not
with you your board but over the
attorney general's office because this
is the first they hear of something like
this
and
i
just wonder why you would think that
if there's a reason why the attorney
general
wouldn't find
it appropriate to take on a case
why the board would find it appropriate
if you would have the same evidence
going forward
and
a follow-up question to that would be
what's going to be done with
the money that is collected that's
because this is money that is going to
the board
and what does the board do with that
money when they take in the fines
sure um so that's a really good question
and just to be clear i am not in any way
trying to impugn the attorney general's
office they are they were a fantastic um
you know office and there are a lot of
diligent people that work very very hard
and they deal with
thousands and thousands and thousands of
complaints i think it would be
physically impossible for them you know
based on their budget structure to
handle
every single uh complaint um you know
that being said
just these two
examples i provided
you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of emotional
aspects involved in pursuing
a lot of these issues and so the
gentleman that i spoke to dealing with
his home that is now you know
where he's exposed to flood insurance as
a result of of a new construction that
he built by relying on you know this
erroneous information he's an older
gentleman and he told me i don't want to
have to go through this i don't want to
have to now spend thousands and
thousands of dollars on an attorney to
go after someone and you know start
filing cases and you know going after
this
i explained that he could file a
complaint with the attorney general and
that certainly you know his right and
and in statute is the disciplinary way
to go
and his answer was well probably nothing
is going to happen out of that um those
were his words not not mine uh you know
i
i agree you know unlicensed practice
should be forcefully
um you know gone after and and that's
why the
law states shall
and felony uh because it it should be a
significant detractor to wanting to do
that
unfortunately what we're seeing
historically is that this this isn't
happening
and um you know as far as what the board
is going to do with the money
you know i can't answer that because i'm
not on the board uh seeing as how this
would be you know a new statute i'm sure
the board would have hearings and you
know
follow all correct procedures on on what
to do and and deal with the money but i
know it would fall under the office of
professional licensure um which again i
don't know how that structure is set up
so
you know there certainly would be
transparent resolution to that
thank you for answering the question and
the only question i have is
the statute already states that they
shall be guilty of
a misdemeanor or if a business that they
shall be a felony upon them and i'm just
trying to figure out how
the board collecting up to a ten
thousand dollar fine is going to help
those aggrieved
homeowners
any further than what the
statute says in
making these folks criminals
so from
from our perspective it's it's it's a
civil deterrent you know um i mean what
we want to do is
certainly let people know look if if you
are going to be providing unlicensed
practice
there is not only going to be this
potential criminal uh
discipline but there's going to be a
monetary a civil monetary aspect of it
and quite honestly you know the majority
of these practitioners are going to be
more afraid of a monetary discipline
than they are of a of a criminal or
or some other kind of discipline and you
know a lot of them their attitude is ah
you know go after me so what you know
it's your job to come after me
for this criminal uh enforcement um
whereas you know a lot of them are going
to be deterred from from practicing
based on the potential of a civil
monetary fine yes if you just uh get
find somebody ten thousand dollars for
every business card they handed out that
says you know surveying services when
they're not licensed that would uh
certainly add up in a hurry
and and that's that's definitely not not
the intent but you know certainly
preventing the the advertising it would
it would certainly
strike me as more
useful
to take somebody that's saying their
quality they're licensed when they
aren't and hitting them up for every
penny you could try to get
and scare off the other people that that
are in the same situation but that's my
opinion
all right representative
pearson and then marsh
thank you madam chair so
i'm going to channel my inner schmidt
just a little bit
i built a 60 000 barn on my property
that had a very limited buildable
footprint right here
and
i can't even imagine
what would have happened if if my
neighbor had later on said hey
you're two feet onto my property i can't
move a six i can't move a barn to that
size it's mo the whole bottom is
concrete right so
it seems as though the effects of
of improperly doing surveys has real and
substantial consequences here
especially when it comes to the erection
of structures and and things of that
nature
but my
the question i have though is when these
surveys are conducted they are submitted
to a local government
body in my case the town of derry
is going to take this
or i suppose if your town doesn't do it
perhaps a county level
takes these
surveys i'll use in quotes would it not
be
appropriate or even advantageous to make
in statute
a provision where a municipality or
political subdivision whatever you want
to call it
cannot accept
a land survive survey of any type from
an unlicensed that way these never get
on file they can they're never used in
any sort of governmental decisions
and they're they're just you know
they're out
would that not assist in
this venture of making sure that things
that we have are done by
licensed people properly
certainly um
i i i don't necessarily think i'm
prepared to speak to
that
now because there's a lot of other
implications um
that go along with that but
but certainly when a town accepts
information
that you know is not
certified by a licensed individual and
um
there is the potential for error in that
and in
the field that i work i i see that
constantly and uh
the example you gave of the barn you
built that's two feet over um
that's more common than you think and
you know we deal with and resolve issues
like that all the time through boundary
line adjustments and agreements and
easements etc so you know we we see the
consequences of that
whether it's
better to have the town a requirement
where the town must accept that
certified work um or not i
i think that's a discussion for
i'm not i'm not saying that the town
needs to accept
something from a licensed survey or what
i'm what i'm getting at is is that if if
you know joe van over here that does
surveying out of the back of a pickup
truck
is now you know you provide you the
service you submit it to your local town
they're gonna go yeah this guy's not
licensed we don't accept i'm not you see
what i'm getting at i do and now when i
go to
when i went to the town of derry and
said you know i want to do this you know
they go all right you got to pull your
survey map to and go through the
planning board process and all that
right but
i took that from the town in good faith
assuming that it was on the up and up
now i know the company that did the
surveying on my land and i know they're
legit but but you see what i'm getting
at if that wasn't legitimately done it
should have it should never have been
something i could have acquired from the
town to start with that's that's kind of
a safeguard that i'm asking you about
here yeah so um i can actually give you
an example of something similar to what
you're talking about uh recently in a
town up in the lakes region
a contractor went to the town got a copy
of a survey plan
which was a boundary line adjustment
the boundary line adjustment
was
stamped by a surveyor showed all of the
boundary lines of the two abutting
properties he took the plan and uh drew
where his garage was going to go it was
a commercial structure
and then he submitted that well it turns
out that boundary line adjustment plan
was never approved by the planning board
nor was it ever you know approved or
accepted by the two abutting owners so
the boundary lines on that plan were
erroneous they did they didn't exist
and it was submitted to the town and
they accepted it as a site plan
application um
had they approved that and gone forward
it didn't fortunately was caught
but but had they gone forward with that
there would have been some significant
problems because the line had changed
and that garage would have then been on
someone else's
property so i mean that's just an
example of kind of what you're outlining
is the information that the towns
have to accept should should come from a
licensed resource but
this is not going to be easy then
representative martian than allegro
uh thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question uh what you're
describing here sounds to me an awful
lot like deceptive business practices
and what i'm wondering is why we're
creating a whole section of law and and
trying to create a mechanism to deal
with these civil fines when we could
just as easily
add this as an item to the list that's
prohibited in rsa358a colon2
again it comes down to enforcement
you know who who is
what
where is the enforcement
mechanism going to come from that's
going to cause more
budgetary resources that's going to
create more significant administrative
costs
and
you know by instituting
a civil money penalty you know not only
are we avoiding
adding these additional administrative
costs that are going to again overburden
our enforcement agencies um but you know
we're going to allow for uh you know a
board to have a legitimate hearing as
they would
during a normal you know licensing um
disciplinary hearing and you know levy a
a fine which then could again provide an
economic offset to the state and the
state budget and the courts and you know
the attorney general's office as opposed
to just adding another item to a list
which is then going to create
again another administrative enforcement
layer
with really no
budgetary enforcement mechanism and you
know that's what we're i think really
trying to get to it at this
at this point
okay thank you representative allegra
thank you
um i think i'm asking a similar question
to representative pearsons but from a
different angle
and i may have a follow-up um
am i correct in assuming that at present
it it is not illegal for a professional
but unlicensed surveyor
to uh provide services
for unofficial use just personal use by
a landowner for example is is that the
case
no
no um you it is illegal to provide
any kind of surveying boundary um
services any of the services that would
fall under the 310 a63 definition of
surveying you know whether it's private
or or not i'm i mean if you're talking
about a scenario where your your friend
um
is going to come over and maybe help you
look for your boundaries or something or
look for maybe the pins or monuments
that are called out in your deed um
just for your own
personal
information um i i don't necessarily
think that would be
encroaching on the illegal and the um
you know practice of
surveying because
your property you still can go out and
search for your own monumentation and
and do that
but if you're talking about
hiring someone
that is going to provide a surveying
service um whether it's
private or whether it's something you
want to submit to a town or municipality
that would still fall under you know the
definition of surveying and still be
enforceable as a as a misdemeanor or
felony
so this is where it ties in with
representative pearson's question is
that
it's a good point that if it's not a
licensed uh provider
then the town should just
not accept it
but what i'm asking here is
not providing it to a town specifically
not providing it to a town so
say there's a pond or a lake or some
feature on my property and i want it
surveyed
i have no intention of using it for
official purposes
and i don't feel like spending a bundle
on a surveyor so i go online i see
somebody who does surveying and they'll
do it for me for a couple hundred bucks
uh just confirming my original question
that would be illegal
so there's currently plenty of firms
online that you can go online enter your
address and they'll provide you with
some kind of an exhibit
you know for your own use they'll say
specifically it's not a survey
that they're not providing surveying
services uh and probably cost you a
couple hundred bucks um we've seen the
prices range per deal between 150 and
300 dollars for for that kind of service
um you know ultimately
the problem we see and certainly in my
experience is that that document always
kind of filters its way
out somewhere else whether it be by you
a subsequent property owner um
some some other information and you know
there can be again confusion as to what
that document is and uh you know we
we see it
quite a lot
thank you
other questions
okay i think that's
that was enough
uh thank you for your testimony thank
you so much for the opportunity william
doucette
good morning my name is bill ducette i'm
the chairman of the board of licensure
for land surveyors
a lot was gone over there and i'm going
to attempt to not be redundant
first relative to the
[Music]
handling of unlicensed practice
so as as was stated the way it is done
today if a complaint comes to the board
and it the complaint is about somebody
who is not licensed
we have no jurisdiction over that
whatsoever
all we can do is refer that to the
attorney general's office and offer our
assistance
um because we feel that you know we do
have uh knowledge that may be helpful to
the ag's
on
distinguishing whether or not
in fact per the definition surveying was
being taken place
um so we offer that assistance
but certainly get the feeling that
these complaints
may not rise to the
level of review
due to the
exceptional burden that the ag has with
with their workload
so
we are not asked
for input
to help assess whether something is
surveying or not
the
example that was given about where a
contractor was setting property corners
that was referred to the attorney
general's office and they found that
that was not surveying
and didn't and did not proceed
so
you you've had some very good questions
today and as the chairman of the board i
don't know the answer to
where the money goes
how to assess whether it's five thousand
or ten thousand we would have to lean on
the oplc
for guidance on how to do that
but our our board and our public member
deal with land surveying on a regular
basis and we understand
what is surveying and what is not
surveying
and we think that we can provide a
valuable role
in assisting
protecting the public from unlicensed
practice
and we think the monetary
penalty that is being suggested
would be a deterrent in
my time on the board and i've been on
the board since 2015
[Music]
the most severe penalty that i have seen
for unlicensed practice was a cease and
desist letter
the most severe penalty that i have seen
imposed on unlicensed practice was a
cease and desist letter
so
it's relative to the other part of this
bill the non-licensed
the non-residential licensure part of
this
so i know of two specific cases one is
in
there's a
long-standing firm that operates out of
portsmouth new hampshire
there's a very qualified individual
she lives in kittery
she's worked most her career at this
firm in portsmouth
and they do their work primarily in new
hampshire she does not have experience
in maine does not have the enough
experience in maine to qualify to even
sit for the main exam
the current law says
you cannot sit for the exam in new
hampshire if you live in another state
and are not licensed in that state
like
attorneys
doctors engineers
there are less and less people coming
into our profession
if we can identify deterrence like this
and
hopefully adjust those so that so that
qualified people can come to us and seek
licensure that would be a great benefit
to all and as was
stated early in the earlier testimony
there's not a project going on in this
state that does never severe involved at
some level
happy to answer any questions
thank you are there representative
schmidt
thank you madam chairman
so mr doucette uh
you and i have spoken on the phone but
it was a long time ago about
surveying in the state of new hampshire
but i'll restrict my questioning to
this particular bill because i'm
questioning whether we're the best
committee to be dealing with this it
seems more like something that a
commerce should be dealing with but uh
you have not flat out stated uh whether
you are in support of this particular
bill as written
so i'd like to ask you that question
first
i am in support of it with the amendment
and i understand that's awkward because
you haven't had a chance to
review the amendment uh there were
in a nutshell the amendment
in my opinion solves a problem where as
written currently if you
it could be read that if you are
licensed in another state
we have to license you
the amendment addresses that we have our
own standards and that includes a
exam that covers new hampshire boundary
law
and that that is very important to the
board um so i am in i am in favor of
this
uh specifically with the amendment as
submitted
follow-up
so uh and you are addressing us as the
chairman of the board and speaking on
behalf of the board and your support of
the bill as amended yes sir thank you
all
right we are getting getting copies of
the amendments we'll be able to analyze
it there any other further questions for
us to do that
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 383
all right
seeing none i will close the public
hearing and i believe this will go to
representative scitec subcommittee
okay
i'm closing the hearing on senate bill
we are resuming at 1pm thank you
okay
thank you
you
opening the public hearing on senate
bill 230 and i call senator cavanaugh
thank you madam chair and committee
members hope everyone enjoyed their
lunch we had a nice commerce meeting
that was just finished as well so it's
great
again my name is kevin cavanaugh senator
from district 16 representing the towns
of beau candia dunbarton hooksett and
manchester wards 1 2 and 12.
i sponsored senate bill 2
and it's a relative the practice of body
art
this bill defines and regulates body art
establishments and is at the request of
pool oplc
and i have been working with
michael porter from the department i can
go on and
bore you with what i don't know but
mike's the uh the expert in this and
more than willing to hand it over to him
thank you that seems pretty clear we
will uh
that case thank you senator and mr
porter thank you
there we go sorry
good afternoon uh honorable members and
madam chairman
my name is michael porter and i'm the
investigations bureau chief at the
office of professional licensure and
certification i'm here today to talk
about senate bill 230
relative to the body art practitioners
i did submit written testimony so i'm
just going to give highlights of that
testimony if that's okay
under current statutes body art
practitioners require individual
licensure but the establishments hosting
licensed body art practitioners do not
the structure proposed by this
legislation mirrors other establishments
requiring licensure including barbering
cosmetology and aesthetics
the proposed legislation provides
proactive measures for the protection of
the public health safety and welfare
licensure of an establishment in
accordance with rules governing any
profession provides a professional
licensing board the ability to inspect
and enforce statutes and rules
proactively without waiting for a
consumer complaint to be filed
while at the same time
boosting consumer confidence
practitioners are properly licensed and
meet minimum standards required of
licensure
under current statutes governing body
art oplc is only authorized to
investigate licensees after a complaint
has been filed
which means the harm may have already
occurred
the proposed legislation primarily
ensures inspectors will have the
flexibility to enter an establishment
for the purposes of routine inspections
to ensure individuals are properly
licensed to perform professional
services
and that basic health and safety
standards are in place
i'm now going to turn to unlicensed
practice
unlicensed activity is a primary concern
in as much as unlicensed practitioners
have not met the minimum requirements
for licensure set by the board including
sanitation and health requirements
unlicensed practice erodes consumer
confidence in the profession and harms
the reputation
professionals who have met the minimum
standards required for licensure
including but not limited to the health
and safety standards
most times unlicensed practice is
discovered as a result of random
inspections
if an establishment is not licensed we
are not authorized to enter for the
purposes of conducting a random
inspection
therefore the likelihood of not
catching unlicensed practice is high
if unlicensed practice is reported by a
consumer or through other means
oftentimes the harm has already occurred
without having the authority to enter an
establishment we are unable to conduct
these random inspections which limits
our ability to discover the unlicensed
practice
many boards have statutes that incur
criminal penalties for individuals
engaged in the license of practice and i
can talk about a couple of cases which
are public now
involving uh aesthetics and barbering
and cosmetology
our inspectors had done some inspections
in the southern tier of the state where
we found um in one particular incident
every employee of the shop was
unlicensed
so because of the fact that we regulate
the
the shop licensure
we were able to expedite an emergency
suspension immediately
through the board the board we brought
our evidence to the board
they immediately suspended the shop
license which meant all operations had
to cease
at the same time we continued to work
with the shop owner to
assist with the licensure licensure
process so that he could open
more rapidly this took about 30 to 45
days what we found were the five or six
individuals were from massachusetts they
were coming up here working unlicensed
and the consumers had no idea
ultimately we we brought them before the
board for a final hearing
they entered into a final settlement
agreement but we also were able to make
a referral to law enforcement because
the shop owner knowingly engaging
employees who are not licensed is a
criminal offense
that case is being prosecuted currently
by the new hampshire attorney general's
office
we had a second case very similar
and i highlight those cases because
without the ability to go in and inspect
we never would have caught these
individuals
operating without a license
subsequently both shops were reopened
both shops are in full compliance with
health and safety
standards
and i believe we we did a second
inspection on both and we were able to
be satisfied with that
so
currently with this particular practice
body art
we do not have the authority to go in
and we do receive phone calls about
unlicensed practice but we can't go into
the establishment we can send a
complaint to the individual a written
complaint
but whether they respond or not
that's really up to them we we have
other measures if they are licensed and
don't respond but if they're unlicensed
then we have no authority and there's
nothing we can do to protect the public
health safety and welfare
we have been working with a number of
municipalities in the southern tier and
on the eastern
side of the state as well
where
many municipalities have told us that
while yes they do have some enforcement
ability they don't have the manpower and
through cobid
they certainly didn't have the manpower
and so in speaking with a number of them
they felt it would be best to have more
of a central repository
such as through oplc to license the shop
give us the authority to inspect if we
find wrongdoing
we already have the authority to reach
out to law enforcement but we'd also
have the authority to reach out to the
public boards of health uh for any
violations that we would find and
trigger that
so
we understand that this is this is a
it's not a large scale measure or
operation but any individual who is
operating without a license
doesn't meet the minimum standards
required and is a harm and threat to the
public health safety and welfare
in conclusion in conclusion the
establishment licensure at the state
level does provide consumers with
confidence that the establishments and
licensees are operating within lawful
means and provides proactive protection
for the public health safety and welfare
proactive measures help identify
issues before they arise
if you have any additional questions or
if you'd like to have a conversation i
can be reached at two seven one zero one
four zero and i'm happy to take any
questions from this committee
thank you mr porter are there questions
from the committee
representative
schmidt thank you madam chair well it's
kind of astonishing in a way to hear
that that you have no authority it seems
inherent it's kind of like uh the
revenuers you know
but of course law enforcement has the
authority that you guys don't have they
can go after any illegal act
but
what these people are doing is illegal
but you but you're not the cops is that
what you're basically saying
in some senses yes
i get a follow-up so do you have any
idea how many uh such operations are out
there that uh that that you're aware of
and you would
stop if you if you
uh had that authority
we we don't track the number of shops
because it's not something that we would
have no way to measure that that
quantity i can tell you during covid
we received a number of phone calls at
the height of covid where people would
complain that a shop was open and there
was very little we could do we would
refer it to the attorney general's
office
um but we did not have authority to go
and inspect and give an explanation if
we have
under cosmetology if a shop was open and
we had an issue i think it was up in
littleton area
uh where we were notified actually by
law enforcement and so we were able to
because of the fact that we had the shop
license uh
and because we regulate that
send them a letter to basically cease
and desist and and stop the practice and
you know in compliance with with the
orders um that person did um he did so
one more so so the thing is you said
that
either you read or you said that the
uh that several
shops were operating illegally and
unlicensed before
uh i guess i couldn't say that they're
illegal if you don't have any authority
but um
uh
and but now they are
up to standard they're operating
what's their excuse for
just ignorance that they
i i can give you a direct quote um we
actually had a public hearing on the
matter um and i actually prosecuted the
matter and uh when the individual
appeared before the board his question
was how many unlicensed people am i
allowed to have in my shop before i get
suspended and that was a legitimate
question that he asked because
unfortunately you know some people think
well i can have one or two and i'm okay
the answer from the board was zero
and in that one that was the one who had
five or six unlicensed
individuals in his shop
the reason we referred that for criminal
prosecution was
really the blase attitude of well how
many am i allowed to have the second
shop owner was not referred for criminal
prosecution because there was a question
as to
what his knowledge base was of those
individuals who he and he did employ
we were able to work with both however
to reopen their shops
legally
and have the protection for the public
health and safety
thank you madam chair and thank you
chief for taking my question sure how
many people in your department actually
go out and
go after the
businesses that are by violating this
so currently we have two inspectors in
the barbering cosmetology unit uh we
have and i don't have the exact numbers
we also have pharmacy inspectors i
believe we have three that work with the
pharmacies
uh we have electrical inspectors there
may be five
five mechanical inspectors and four
electrical so
dedicated to this in this bill is a
request for
another position which we would need to
assist um in the inspections of these
shops
thank you are there other questions
yes representative fontenot
yes thank you madam chair
um can can you would this uh would this
fall under your barbering cosmetology
division or would this be a
new separate
division so it would be held it would be
housed in the enforcement division um
and so you know what what the specs
would look like as far as qualifications
we would have to work that out
internally uh but they would just be
another inspector within our division of
enforcement can you tell me in general
in this oh follow up
in general in the state
how many other of the professions
require the business to be licensed as
well as the individuals to be licensed
i can only tell you what we have
jurisdiction over and that would be for
the barbering cosmetology they have shop
licenses um they also have apprentice
licenses and then there's barbarian
cosmetology or aesthetics
um that is the only
uh
i believe the only enterprise that we
uh plumbers and electricians have a
business license that is required as
well as the individual licenses right
and i believe that's not enforceable
with us i believe that's a separate
we have individual licensure with them
but right now they're the only shops
that i believe they're the only shops
that we regulate correct
i'm sorry pharma yes pharmacies also uh
they receive permits to operate their
pharmacies through
uh oplc as well
thank you
other questions
yes representative yes thank you
thank you mr porter yes uh
you
i would like to know if you never have a
case someone
operated with a fake license
here in new hampshire
i'm sorry if
someone if you never have a case someone
being appropriated with a fake license
or a funny license yep okay do you have
that case in new hampshire
so i
i'm not aware of any um
well we we've we've dealt with some
altered and doctors like doctored
licenses uh they might have fudged out
the expiration date but it's somebody
who was previously licensed um but i
don't believe we've run into that
situation where somebody has duplicated
a a a fake license and hung it not that
i'm aware of okay all right thank you
any other questions representative
fellows
i i'm um
i see on the first page
on
line
11.
i'm just gonna grab a copy
i apologize for that around
line 11 on the first page it talks about
the fact that that if the establishment
is already licensed under
apparently anything
that's under
oplc
that
for the body art
establishment license they would have a
reduced fee
and and then on page two
it says
at the top of page two a condition that
oh it has this it has essentially the
same thing and that
the establishment
here's my my question
so i'm wondering how big this scope is
and
if the manager you could have a manager
that really doesn't know anything about
body art but they could have body art in
their establishment so uh so can you
straighten that out
and i'll use and i hate to keep going
back to my catch-all but uh barbarian
cosmetology
you don't have to be a licensee to
operate a shop
you do require a shop license
and again
the individuals you hire to conduct the
services have to have the license in
that profession
um but we that still gives us the
authority
that if they hire unlicensed
practitioners
we at least have the authority to go in
right away if the board so chose to
suspend the shop license which closes
everything until they come into
compliance so you don't have to be
a body art practitioner in order to own
the shop
yes you really have to make sure there
is a an appropriately licensed person
who runs it you don't have to have a
license to own it
but you need
a manager
who's
licensed
under something yes for example if you
if you're
if your hairdresser wanted to put a
little uh tattoo
chair in the back of the salon they
would not need they would get a cut rate
on the
body yard facility license
okay thank you
other questions
yes
i have a a comment the as as you see on
line
the
the board already has rule making
authority over inspection
of body art establishments
that's in current law
yes
it's on page
1 line
14 of the bill you can see it lined out
and so my question is
if you have if you can make rules about
it that implies you can do it
so
so yeah i so and i'm not familiar with
the statute and i'm going to guess but
this statute might be under the rule
making authority of the board itself
um as the executive director the
body artisan advisory board correct um
so
the problem is we there's no statutory
enforcement of that and so
it's the process by which
and i'm i'm not i can't answer that
directly but i can tell you that if it's
made by rule
we do we do issue rule violations but a
statutory violation
which then makes it a potential criminal
penalty
um is what would follow through and
this is really a two-pronged attempt the
first is to ensure
that anybody who opens a shop you know
is licensed and they're responsible for
the activities that go on in their shop
and if they hire unlicensed individuals
if we don't have the authority to go
after the unlicensed person for whatever
the reason we do have legal authority
under the law to hold the shop owner
responsible
it's it's a little convoluted at times
and that's why we were looking for this
language in this statute okay because
the i've happened to be looked further
down in the statute
and it's in 3 14 a 12 a person who shall
practice or attempt to practice
tattooing body piercing branding without
a license shall be guilty of a class a
misdemeanor or
or a felony if you're you're a business
and then again if you violate any other
provision of the chapter or rules
adopted this chapter guilt shall be
guilty of a violation or felony of your
business for a first offense
so
since
that sounds that you would adopt rules
saying that the
you have
the authority to enter a business
and
and in there you will see
whether the employees are licensed
sorry i'm just reading that i'm catching
up to you it's uh
anyway that's that's for your
information
i think
not sure you don't have that the
authority already
it's
so my understanding and again it's and
i'd have to take a look at this a little
bit more the complexity but it's my
understanding that we we just can't go
in
and and for example we'll get a phone
call or an email that says hey you know
uh so and so is operating an illegal
shop and we don't there's very little we
can do about that piece of it
we could reach out to a licensee if they
happen to be working there to find out
are you licensed but
we generally don't hear about those
unless
there's a complaint that comes in but i
can take a look at this further and get
back to you okay thank you any other
questions
all right oh yes representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
are these people basically hiding in
plain sight or are they really hiding
uh
some are not
some are in plain sight some are not it
varies it depends on on the shop itself
it varies thank you
okay other questions
for examples
mike
sorry
on the last page it talks about giving
it talks about establishment license
so you can give in a step well
issue an establishment license to
somebody who's a licensed body art
practitioner
although
i don't even know why that needs to be
in there because the next paragraph says
you can give it a license establishment
license to somebody who's not
provided that
you can give it to the owner provided
that the licensed body art practitioner
he employs
a licensed body
art practitioner as manager
so do you have a definition of manager
and does that conflict with what
the last question i asked you about
about on page one
because on page one it says
they can be the manager can
have
have a
certification or
in
cosmetology or something it doesn't have
to be body art and here it says body art
it specifically says that the licensed
body art practitioner is manager so
um
the the
but the owner is the person who has to
apply for it
right but on the with the other page it
said the manager could be anybody who
was licensed
under anything under oplc
right right and therefore the
person who was doing the
body arc in the back of your hair salon
would have to be the licensed manager
i get that part
oh well
but on the first page it doesn't say
that you could have somebody with a
cosmetology
license be the manager
and
and the body art is one person in the
back
i thought we thought we just
confirmed that
does it sound it sounds like a conflict
to me
uh i think we if
we'll have to look into that for you
any further
questions seeing none thank you mr
porter thank you
yes um is this one of the early bills no
okay thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 230.
okay
seeing none thank you i will close the
hearing
and
i'll mention this has a lot of
similarity with the house bill regarding
the
licensure of
massage establishments that we have an
interim study
yeah it does yeah
[Music]
here we got 20 minutes
it might be
oh four three we need the the amendment
from
representative representative pearson do
you have the amendment to send a bill
443 what i don't have
okay so we're not quite ready he's going
to be here
okay
but yes i do have okay good
and
does someone have a want to make a
motion on senate bill 325
which is the first bill we heard
i think so yes
start 325 is local organization for
emergency management
representative pearson you have a motion
sure i'll make a motion on how to pass
on 325.
okay
the reason thank you madam chair
part of the reason is i want to make
sure that the majority
blurb is very clear on intent because
that is part of the legal
record of this
and i want to reiterate senator
kavanaugh's
clear
statement that this is not intended to
modify anyone's classification in the
pension system
um
this also
for the most part
as we as we heard in the in the hearing
a lot of this is kind of just a
recognition a feel-good thing
the only thing substantive of this
is that this may just make the path to
federal reimbursement for
some declared emergencies just just that
little bit easier
but this doesn't really
this doesn't really change anything too
drastically that's not already being
done
thank you representative
lackas
uh thank you uh i was stuck in the
senate so um pearson or someone if you
could uh just give me an
overview of your view of what this thing
does thank you i'd be happy to
so for the most part
um
this is kind of feel good oh
it really is as far as just recognizing
some of the ancillary groups
that have participated in
not just recently this is really
irrespective of cove but this goes back
to all kinds of stuff actually really
mostly weather related
in its in its scope than anything else
but
it's just to the point of recognizing
that beyond just what we consider the
typical first responders
we have other folks that have been
pressed into service for various things
including you know the department of
transportation local road agents local
highway departments and things of that
nature
that involved anything from floods to
washouts to
blizzards really so
it doesn't this doesn't change the
structure of anything like i said it
just really
at best would
make it a little easier for the state
when they file for federal reimbursement
on declared emergencies
to
just have their paperwork a little bit
more
in a row and that's honestly really all
it is yeah follow up follow up so if i
understand correctly that last part
since uh we're saying they are um
involved in responding to emergencies
then you know we could file for
reimbursement with the feds if on an
emergency and that
other than the recognition in that
aspect of it this basically does nothing
is that correct it one thing it does
is that it explicitly says that
public works or the road agent or
whomever
will be part of the incident command
structure
all right but let's see but they
generally are there now anyway they are
there now yeah
it's a it's a term called unified
command and i won't get into how the
unified command system works but that's
it's it's uh like i said there's really
not a huge change here to what we're
currently doing
okay thank you representative schmidt
and then allegro
thank you madam chair so one of the
things that i'm familiar with and i just
want to ask you because you're clearly
the most experienced among us with
regard to this particular issue uh and
for example one of the common events
that happens in cities is
in the wintertime you have a sewer line
break in
where the people got to get out there
and
dig open the street
to get at it to stop the flow and so
forth and so on
these people are going to be
acknowledged in the same fashion by this
bill
probably not i mean realistically you
know
it would be one colossal humongous water
main for the governor have to declare a
state of emergency or water main break
so
you know that's i think that's a little
bit of a underwhelmed
event
for what this really is intended to do
this is more large scale over
big scope stuff
because the reality is
in if you're talking about the dead of
winter
and the line breaks and those guys are
out there breaking open the street
and struggling with uh
with water and collapsing uh terrain
around
the break and so forth and so on that
that's nothing to to uh to joke about i
i'm not saying you were joking uh but
it's it's uh it's serious stuff uh so it
may not be worthy of a gubernatorial uh
declaration i'm not implying that it
should it's just that i would like to
that serious stuff as well as fires
thank you representative schmidt
representative allegra
i'm going to need to be convinced to
support this one it seems to me like an
open-ended
and unnecessary expansion well it's a
change of definition
and
as the representative earlier said
representative pearson mentioned it's
not
it
it doesn't have anything to do with
compensation and that kind of stuff and
insurance but
it will
we know that this is the first step
in the ever expanding definition and and
then
treatment of different positions now
you know i mean things are listed in
here like hospital workers
a nurse
a surgeon in the hospital
is not a first responder
the first responder police fire
and a few others
and we just keep expanding the deficit
and definition of first responder
there's no end to it
um and so like i say i need i'm gonna
need to be convinced on this one thank
you
okay any other comments representative
o'brien
ah thank you madam chair
to representative allegro and to others
uh i remember going and taking uh
several classes on the incident command
system
and one of the examples that they
brought up is
a plane crash it did actually happen was
in pennsylvania
and
in this particular case a local pizza
shop
came up and said
we'll supply pizzas
to the first responders
at this particular incident
and pretty soon they found out that the
emergency workers were not eating the
pizzas
and then somebody came up with the
bright idea that's exactly what they're
looking at at the crash scene
so the thing is
when you look at the incident command
system it's supposed to be a flexible
document okay that can be
handled as small as you want but it all
also can be expanded and to have people
such as public works at a particular
incident now in the case of a blizzard i
don't know but living through
78 at best day
some fire companies wish they had a plow
company a plow municipal plow running in
front of them to get to some areas down
the street particularly if they had a
fire if that was done through a command
post at that time in 78 the incident
command system did not exist
but in that type of situation
the uh public works could target target
that particular area
so what this does to me
uh it's already happening yeah but it
does codify it to make sure
and it i think it's part of the
enlightening of looking at the incident
command system that it is a flexible uh
procedure that can get into it could be
logistics
it's fine when they end in two hours but
you could have a situation that could
last
months
and that's where you really need a very
strong incident command system and this
could involve public works working for
that period of time
the fire department may actually
de-escalate and become into some of the
ancillary groups that would actually
become more prominent in that regard
thank you
yes
representative but if it lasts for
months they're not first responders
first responders are there on the scene
at the time
and issues about and i'm not being
facetious here honestly who gets pizza
who gets fed that kind of thing those
aren't decisions that require an
expansion of the definition
of first responder
that just requires some common sense on
the scene you got people there they're
working they can't go home they got to
get some food
give a slice of pizza
thank you
okay um
representative bailey and then o'brien
thank you madam chair
um
i have not been best pleased with the
both of either the scope or the duration
of the most recent emergency
and i
do not like that there are people in
this list of first responders that are
not public
employees and that that
needs to change or i need to vote no
thank you
okay uh representative pearson
so sir representative bailey i'll give
an example the city of manchester right
now is ems services provided by amr by
contract
that's who provides ambulance service
they are not employees of the city of
manchester or any actual governmental
group it's a contracted private entity
uh the city of nashville functions under
the same manner so in the event of a
even a cessna landing on elm street in
manchester that's going to require an
integrated act with the
ambulance company
so
non-governmental employees are
integrated into disaster relief
all the time this is extremely common
and it has been for a hundred years
so i'm not sure what your concern is in
the fact that that they're not
necessarily public employees
okay
roxanna for monty
thank you manager um
i i would imagine i would address this
question to you
is not first responders
actually anyone that
comes across the scene
preferably licensed like a licensed
nurse a medic in the military or
situations like that and then when the
crew comes or the fire crew or the
ambulance
that automatically gets turned over to
them but wouldn't that person be the
first responder
the first person on the scene
the the term first responder applies to
if you will it's been it's been
deemed into more professional
categories right so
fire fire police and fire are always
first responders regardless of
if an incident's an hour or a month
so that's
but to your point
you know roll over on the highway you've
got active military guys that pull over
a nurse whatever
um
are they first responders are they good
samaritans
i think that i think the term first
responder really does more apply to more
of a professional
role to which it is your duty to act if
you will versus
a good samaritan role per se
if and if i'm not answering your
question right please tell me if if
you're not if i'm not explaining myself
right
yeah
i'll give you a good example um
say the coast guard uh
the uh you know the coast guard
auxiliary um they
would be if they came across a an
accident anywhere they would be
considered first responders they're not
employed by the government they're on
their own own
501 seat group but sure they would be
see the there's a there's a whole
program on this licensing first
responders thing
and i understand it a little bit
differently than it was explained to you
because civil air patrol is a good
another example they're not military
they're they're a
pseudo
military organization that provides a
service
and they have
some statutory jurisdictional things
involving plane crashes but that would
be yeah i mean i would consider the
civil air patrol first responders too
and that and they may be and that their
their legal classifications and
definitions probably include that term
but
um
there's a there is a difference between
emergency response and emergency
management and that's been a big topic
of conversation during the covert era as
to when that when you go from emergency
response to just management so
i think in this particular case what
we're talking about here isn't
necessarily the rebuilding of a bridge
that washed out and six months later
we're putting a bridge back together
that that's not first response that's
that's just management or reconstruction
i think what we're getting here is the
folks that are
involved in an initial incident that
have been either
through their own
statutory function been involved or
through conscription been
involved into mitigating what's in an
emergency
as far as hospital folks hospital folks
have been used in that role
before i mean we've pulled people out of
hospitals for
we've pulled surgeons out of hospitals
for accidents on the highway where we've
had to do some serious work
and
that's um
it's fairly rare
it's fairly rare but they they do fall
under that i i see your concern with
this and and i that's why i asked
senator cavanaugh you know i'm not
looking
for this to become a catalyst to change
people's classifications as far as the
pension system or benefits or anything
else
i think this is just more of a of a like
representative o'brien said we're
codifying something that already exists
and we're just kind of making it a
little bit more formal
in its statute
um
rhodes
thank you madam chair so
i think this is a little bit of my
thought with um representative allegro's
question
and
along with what representative o'brien
was saying so the particular plane crash
that he's speaking of um was about five
miles from my backyard
and there actually were no survivors of
the plane crash however there were other
emergencies that were around that area
that
all of the local hospitals like in the
event there would have been any
survivors right the local hospitals
would certainly have been
first responders because it would be the
management of that that particular
crisis at that time right so you would
gather
anybody
there so you know when you go to school
for the training
for the the first response if you will
in the crisis management all of the
local hospitals would be would be
involved in all of that it doesn't go on
forever that would be that emergency for
right then
i'm not sure if that answered your
question but
no both you and pearson actually gave me
some good wording but but that's exactly
the point when when the plane crashed
people didn't pick up the phone and call
the hospital
they picked up the phone and they called
the professional people who were
supposed to be there immediately and on
the spot
yeah but you can go on
infinite these are like that yes the
these this list includes the people
that the
first person first professional on the
scene was calling in the first
round that the first that the first
responder was calling
do you want to put it that way yes
representative i can tell you in a mci
mass casualty incident scenarios and
trainings and preparedness every single
person that's in this category and in
article nine is included in those is
those preparedness drills every single
one of them
so
you know that this is this is not um
like i said this is not long-term
management stuff this is
this is initial stuff
so
every there's not a single entity here
that's listed that that i would not
include in a mass casualty drill
okay representative marsh and then i'm
going to recess this discussion
to clarify a little bit about the
hospitals i want to
as a hospital trustee i happen to know
that what our emergency room personnel
do in the emergency room is they
communicate by radio to the emts on
scene and actually give orders to things
that have to be done at the time of an
incident so they're intimately involved
in what's happening on the scene even if
they're not physically on that scene at
that point in time okay
we will continue this after the next
hearing so
stay tuned and
you're going to run that because i've
got the
the member
senator carson brought in a card but i
don't we'll see if she's here
are you able to introduce it for me
okay
we are opening the public hearing for
senate bill 358
and
ms wheeler
good afternoon committee members my name
is chantelle you're gonna have to eat
that markiplier
is that better closer
all right my name is chantel wheeler i
am here on behalf of senator sharon
carson who represents the towns of
auburn londonderry and hudson and i'm
here to introduce for your consideration
senate bill 358 which just establishes
october 2022 as eczema awareness month
um
could i could i trouble you maybe to
bring that down or bring it we're having
a really hard time hearing you i know
you're trying i just
you really do have to eat the microphone
it's ridiculous all right is this better
that is thank you
do you want me to start over
no that's that's okay i i think i heard
enough of it all right so i'm here to
introduce this bill which would
establish october 2022 as eczema
awareness month there are over 30
million people who suffer with eczema in
the united states it's a debilitating
condition
and with that i have
no further introduction
are there any questions from zwiller
representative pearson
i'm not sure that you can answer this
but i'll give it a shot has the prime
sponsor
senator carson just reach out to the
governor to ask for just a simple
declaration or proclamation from the
governor's office rather than do this in
statute i don't i don't know the answer
to that question i know this bill was
passed last
session and died in uh in the omnibus
sure
okay thank you
no further questions thank you very much
who else do i have
i guess nobody
okay
representative mcguire
yes thank you i'm here to
carol mcguire representing allenstown
epsom in pittsfield and merrimack 29
and
i have here a non-germane amendment to
senate bill 358
which i will say assumes
the position that the committee will not
support it and therefore it completely
replaces the bill
if i'm wrong it could easily be changed
to
tack on to the bottom of the bill
in any event this came out of
discussions we had
on house bill
1395 where which talked about the jail
car process
and this is a
change to the committee
that came out of some discussions i had
with other people in the house
what it does is that it increases the
number of members of jail car
and
separates it into three
divisions as it were
and the reason for that is that
the people who are serve on jail car are
primarily from edna
and a few from finance what we don't
have is people with
real knowledge about the other areas we
write rules
and so
this jail car staff
you know will make sure it agrees with
the letter of the law but it's
rather difficult
to understand the effect if you don't
understand the
subject of the
uh
of the rule there is plenty of expertise
in the house on all these different
areas
and so by increasing the number of
people who serve on jail car and
concentrating them in areas of expertise
you'll be able to get more intelligent
review of the rules
and better compliance with the
legislative intent
for example it in a lot of cases
there are a lot of rules about health
and human services
and we know some things about it but
there's
other things that other that other
people who in the house would have a
better knowledge of it would be more
capable of saying you know this
this may come may more or less comply
with the law but it doesn't comply with
legislative intent or
this is a bad way to do something and
that's
the problem with one of the problems
with administrative rules is that
they're frequently written by people who
aren't as knowledgeable as they ought to
be
and therefore
they don't have the
deep understanding of the subject that
you would
ideally have
so what this this this amendment
adds up
adds people 15 members of the
of the house
nine members of the house and six
members of the senate rather than five
and five at the moment
and
separates them into three groups
of five
and so that you get
more
more concentrated expertise in each
section
and there's
the the only other significant change is
that it would require the entire
committee
all 15 members to get together to vote
to make a final objection
and submit a
um
a resolution to block the implementation
of a rule and require a vote of the full
of the full house and senate
so i will try to answer questions if i
can
representative lekkis
thank you um
so looking through this we got it i i
didn't see anything that decided what uh
division would handle what subject and
how it'd be broken up is that just going
to be decided by the committee chair or
the committee
i would suspect it would like many other
things it would depend on what rules are
coming up
are likely to come up or
what the particular
interest and knowledge of the
uh committee members is but yes i i left
it up to the discretion of the chair
follow-up
recognize for follow-up thank you uh so
that means that uh individual members of
uh
the committee wouldn't
always be assigned to the same division
that might move based on what rules were
coming in or i think would be easier if
they were standing
so i would expect that to be the case in
most circumstances all right thank you
representative grota then pearson
representative luck is did ask my
question and i
um
i was particularly interested in
standing committees so it would be
similar to what we do in this committee
when we have standing subcommittees and
we have a bill that needs to be hashed
out we send it to that subcommittee
right is that right
yeah or in finance they do the same yes
okay thank you
representative pearson
thank you madam chair
looking at this your your uh
you're committing 20 of the senate
okay to this
and based on
a lot of discussion we've heard this
year the senate is already
overworked according to them so is this
something that
i know it's your amendment and you're on
it by yourself but is this something the
senate's down like okay with as far as
20 of the senate being committed to jail
car there are two answers to that first
we have in fact discussed this with
members of the senate and
they have not expressed extreme pleasure
or displeasure so
the other thing is that
the structure of jail car is such that
there are there's a full complement of
alternates and it is not at all uncommon
even now where there's
five senate members and five house
members and five house alternates to
have
one or more of or of the senators
be replaced by house alternates
there are senate alternates too and they
show up when they when they they're
interested
what thank you
so it
with the restructuring here at some
point there would have to be
what constitutes a quorum
so the quorum of a division shall be
three members
with
five being a full complement if i'm
getting that right based on the math
okay
the
as far as the
three divisions are they
the chairs of those
are they staggered is it
is the house
versus the senate i mean who's the
for the full committee the chair rotates
it's the senate this session it'll be
the house next session and if i didn't
put that in that's a good thing to
include for the divisions
that would be the intent okay
representative marsh
thank you i
found the answer to my question wait a
minute excuse me senator pearson if you
look on page 29
the the chair shall rotate biannually
between the house and senate members
right that's the over the overall
encompassing 15 member body right yes
and ag and
it doesn't say the same applies to these
divisions but it it
it it could easily say so okay
i i found the answer to my question okay
are there any more questions
um yeah this is just to get back to the
what what is the scope of each division
and it seems to me that if the
speaker and the president of the senate
are going to appoint members
to the
do they appoint the members to the
divisions or
or
uh
that maybe somehow somehow it needs to
specify either what the divisions are
going to be in statute or
some mechanism to determine what it is
before the people are appointed that was
just my thought
um
it's an interesting thought right now
if anybody is appointed to jail car and
shows a willingness to continue they
will be reappointed for as long as they
show that willingness
[Laughter]
and what i would hope that the
criteria would be
would to have
as wide a range of expertise
as you can possibly get because
of the 400 of us you know no matter what
it is somebody's an expert
but if you're only talking you know five
members now or nine members
you know you want to get
people who have a widely varying
expertise and experience
and not all for me dna yes
i mean the the
one of the reasons that we have problems
with rules is that
too many
legislators don't take them very
seriously
and so you don't get the involvement in
the rules
even though they have the effect of law
and
the the more people from different
committees and different backgrounds we
can get involved
the more likely it is that we will help
the agencies produce good rules
so
are there any more questions for
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question
um and looking at the amendment
as you know i sat in the initial
discussions we had with the speaker and
uh
the initial draft that came forward
um
that was sent out to us when we had that
working group
had
nine members from the house
and it
changed it to do from there it went from
five of who should be from the same
party
this amendment before us changes that to
six from the same party i'm
asking if you'd be willing to go back to
that five i think it makes it more
workable and it keeps the percentages
back to where they were with the
original three pips
that was a request of the speaker and i
will
he who is going to be
who is going to be testifying next and
um
i'll go along with whatever you guys
agree i
we you need to have a solid presence
from both parties i agree with that and
i agree i i understand i i know joe kai
when they work they
generally don't work wrong party lines
they work as a working group for the
best interest in making sure the rules
are and so i'm just hoping we can stay
closer to the center thank you
are there any further questions
thank you chairman maguire
mr speaker
uh thank you and
members of the committee um
[Music]
as representative probably just said
this is something that
we've been working on
realistically for probably the past 10
years
trying to come up with some solutions to
fix gel car
and
gel car has been given an almost
impossible task
if you look at the amount of paperwork
they're giving on any given day when
they meet
uh it can be you know this much
paperwork on on a table
and um
i mean i'll use the analogy of
uh we'll pass a one paragraph bill in
the legislature
and they'll
the the
separate department will come up with a
50 60 page
list of administrative rules
i've seen it happen
and what we're trying to do here is to
make it more effective and more
realistic
so that
the amount of things coming back and
i've had to do this myself a number of
times through the years
where i've gone to the administrative
roles
and i'm saying this isn't what we passed
and um
when i served all those years on
transportation and i said this isn't
what we passed this wasn't the intent
and they put it in administrative rules
and then we had to go back and fix it
is this going to be the solution
probably not completely
but
this is a start
now there's some other things that we
talked about
and uh something that i've felt is
needed
is that
maybe and i can't remember when we had
our meetings who suggested it is maybe
every committee in the house
will have a separate subcommittee to go
over the rules too before they go to
jail car to make sure that they're the
intent of what the legislation was
passed
that could be the next step
so this is the first step
um
i truly believe it's going to help
make a better set of rules coming out of
gel car
especially if it acts like the
fiscal committee does
where a department
certain departments are
regularly
you know are appointed to each one of
the
finance committee divisions
and i'm assuming that this is the
basically the same way that this will
work
uh you'll have the you know five house
members and uh the senate members and
they'll
you know hopefully work with their
expertise on that uh on that sub on that
uh division of gel car
i can tell you um having worked on
appointing members to gel car a number
of times
um
it's worse than pulling teeth
in many cases uh some people love it
uh i know peter's been on it for uh
years 16 years and god bless you
but uh
you know it's been very hard to define
because of the intensity of the amount
of work that you get uh when gel car
meets
this is one step forward uh we've got
some other things um
that hopefully uh through the years
we'll be able to move forward with
is it going to be the
solution
i guess we won't know until we try it
but what we're doing right now
isn't the solution and so this is the
first step moving forward
as far as the numbers representative
i think that's i'm open to
you know that
are there any questions for the speaker
look at you out of the hot seat so quick
everybody's scared out of their minds to
ask him
[Laughter]
now's your chance representatives
thank you mr speaker okay thank you
representative schmidt
okay so for the record peter schmidt
representing dover wards one and two
which is stratford
district 19
20 years in the house
16 years on jail car
um i wouldn't say i love it but it's
something that has to be done
um and
i don't have a family so i have more
time than most of you probably do
although i i have a life as well
but
i i have to
oppose this idea because i think it is
fundamentally wrong-headed and i will
tell you why
you have to understand that
that the
executive branch is granted a certain
amount of the
power of the legislature to make
laws
rules are
have the force and effective laws
um
as it has already been alluded to by
representative mcguire
and
so
but as a trade-off for the
[Music]
uh for the authority that is given to
the executive branch to make those laws
there is a jail car in the state of new
hampshire in any case
which has the power to
vet those rules
to see that the
uh that the rules that are written
by the executive branch departments uh
do not ex primarily they're therefore
pillars of objection but the two main
ones are
a rule cannot exceed legislative
authority
can't it can't permit more than
the
statute permits
and the other one is it can't violate
legislative intent
i think those are pretty
straightforward and understandable
you can ask me a question if you have
one
but
uh that's what gel car does
the idea that you're going to have a gel
car which is as expert
as
the
professions that it writes rules for
is just fundamentally wrong-headed
the rules are not written by
legislators the statutes are written by
legislators but very often
those of you who've been here for a
while or even for a relatively short
period of time know that very often the
the
bills that we
that we vet in our committees are bills
that come from outside
right
they come from outside
and not necessarily from a citizen who
has an idea sometimes the citizens have
ideas that are good sometimes they have
ideas that frankly are pretty bad
or unworkable in terms of legal
voting and legal basis
so
if you have
a statute which
says what it says
gets adopted by the legislature signed
off on by the governor
then
something is going to have to be done by
and large to implement that statute
and that's the rule that's written
and that rule is going to be more
precise because it's kind of like
the difference between a blueprint and a
house
the
print may be the basis but it doesn't
have every nail in it
it doesn't have any every
every aspect of the house
the builders have to come up with that
and so uh the the rule is going to be
longer
than the statute overwhelmingly but but
that doesn't mean that it's going to be
and i have to disagree with the
speaker's characterization that a
one-page statute can have a 60-page rule
uh i've been doing this for 16 years
i've never seen anything like that
it's going to have more because it has
all the details in it
but the rule but the rule is written
not by
by
some
legislative body it's written by
the
agency that
that oversees that particular field
and the people in that agency
are
very heavily experienced in that area
and they work together with the
profession that that statute is going to
govern and that rule is going to is
going to govern
and therefore
it's a give and take
and when the agency's done writing the
rule
then
there's a public hearing
no that's not the jail car hearing it's
the first hearing after the rule is
written
and after that
give and take and back and forth has
happened
and the stakeholders that is the
profession that is going to be
influenced and
regulated there
has an opportunity to say
that won't work we don't like that and
so forth and so on
and
the agency has to take that into
consideration they can't just ignore it
because one of the members of the jail
car and you're looking at him will
always ask
this point that you're bringing up in
the i have to say there's a second
public hearing
and that's the public hearing before
jail car
and i always ask if there's any if
there's any public testimony
this objection that you're bringing up
mr
practitioner
was that objection brought up in the
in the fat first public hearing
and if it was brought up
and it's not reflected
in some change in the rule
that doesn't
incline me to vote to approve that rule
representative schmidt could i ask you
to speak specifically to the to
to the amendment
not necessarily to
what exactly joe carr is doing now
but the amendment is going to change
the makeup of jelcar
in order to better
get into
the substance of the rule
we the argument is we need more
expertise on the part of
uh
of the members of the gel car because we
they they don't know enough about things
other than several of us who are on edna
which has a lot of overlap with
uh which elkhart that's one of the
reasons when i got appointed to edna
16 years ago i also got put on the gel
car
okay
i get to testify madam chair okay
and but the thing is
i understand what i'm talking about
because i've been doing it for 16 years
and in that time i've missed i think two
meetings gelco meets once a month
at least every month
that's one of the defects
that's one of the defects of this
proposed fix
[Music]
that the suggestion that that we're
going to have the committees vet the
rules
that's just not going to work
because the committees only function
from january
to june at the latest then we're off the
rest of the time
who's going to vet the rules on the rest
of the year
we have a one meeting every month and if
it's needed we have two meetings a month
okay
and they go on for as long as we have
business to deal with
so uh so
this concept is just not going to work
for one thing
more members
from this from the house on the basis of
expertise the expertise is not going to
be in the house it's in the agency or
the department that writes the rule in
conjunction with the practitioners of
the rule
the expertise is already there
what does the gel card do
it doesn't really vet the rule either
the rule is vetted by the three
full-time attorneys that the jail car
employs
they go over the rule
every aspect of the rule if it's a
semicolon in place of a comma or vice
versa that gets fixed if it should be
there and not there that all gets fixed
that's nitpicky kind of stuff but also
the rule has to absolutely implement the
statute to the greatest degree possible
and if it doesn't implement the statute
the attorneys will say there's a
conflict with this statute or that
statute in other words you've got
statutes butting heads usually it's the
new statute which is deemed to have
uh the greater sway because it's the
more recent statute
but sometimes you get a budding and
they'll and the then the jail car
attorney will show with arrows and so
forth you have to look at this to see
how it looks
so
the idea that that the uh that the jail
car attorneys are overwhelmed i don't
know they they bring in the rules every
time that they've they've gone over and
they'll say uh you know this this is a
problem here
and then the agency gets gets to come in
and and and they get to testify and they
get to say uh this is the reason we're
doing it this way
and since the agency is the one that's
actually overseeing and working with the
public
and if they say this is the only way we
can do it
then by and large the jail card will se
and the attorneys will say
the jail card the previous gel card 10
years ago had the same objections and
the and the gel car approved it
so it's not a willy-nilly
jamming stuff down people's throats the
public has a great deal of involvement
in the
the development of rules and the agency
has the expertise not the legislature
it's the agency that has the expertise
one other aspect that's very important
to understand and that is
that getting people to serve on the gel
car the speakers you know
alluded to the fact that i
have been on for a long time he said he
implicitly said i love it i don't love
it but i recognize that it has to be
done and it's better to have somebody do
it that knows what he's doing
representative schmidt will you take
questions i will
representative pearson thank you i
i have a
couple
um one of them is
you made a comment about the committee's
vetting the rules
i don't think that's what's going on
here the committees themselves are not
vetting the rules they're making up
they're expanding jail car in
but the you know if there's a if there's
a health and human service related
question it's not going to the health
and human services committee i'm
alluding to the fact that the speaker
said this is only a first step he he had
acknowledged this probably won't work
i agree with him that
this probably might work okay so i've
got to deal with what's what's in front
of me
not the theory of what's going to happen
he said he said we'd like to get to the
point where the committees are going to
view the rules
you want to come back in the summer time
all every month
for five or six hours to go over
uh you know a 15 page or 30-page rule
that's not in here
we already virtually cannot find enough
senators to to meet the quorum
requirements right now so my second my
second question for you representative
schmidt is in your 16 years have you not
ever seen
an agency overstep its authority
i i can give you a specific example
where the committee over the agency
overstepped the authority and that was
when the
smoking ban was
was put through but there was no hammer
there was no sanction
therefore the agency the agency said
this is going to be
ignored
if there's no sanction and so they put
in a fifty dollar administrative fine
you're recognized for following the
attorney said
there's no basis for this so we
as a jail car we voted for a joint
resolution saying
there's no authority for this the agency
agreed but they said
this is going to have no effect if
there's no hammer
well you okay and that and you've
alluded into my third question here that
involves attorneys
it
you're
from what i'm gathering what you're
saying is that really jail car should
just be a handful of attorneys
and not
because because you've made statements
in reference to will the attorneys hash
it out the attorneys determine this
i think this goes a little you know i'm
not subjugating the authority of the
legislature to a handful of attorneys in
a committee to to oversee rules and
that's not what jail car is so clearly
it's more than just
a handful of gel car attorneys deciding
what flies and what doesn't right
the attorneys
look at whether the rule implements the
statute
it does not exceed legislative authority
it does not violate legislative intent
if the rule does that the attorneys put
on the consent calendar
just like we have a consent calendar in
the house you're all familiar with
there's also a
consent calendar on gel car
and if the attorneys say this rule meets
the statutory requirements implements
the statute perfectly it goes on the ins
consent calendar
any member of the gel car can pull it
off just like we can take off any
anything in the house
but the
if if if the rule is perfect
we don't ordinarily do anything except
adopt the the
jail car consent calendar
with one vote the same way it happens in
the house but if there's a problem
where the attorneys say this is
this is does not
in our opinion does not meet the statute
perfectly
the
the agency is going to get to argue for
why they want to do it that way and
that's the only way to do it and the
jail car can then say
we understand why you can do it
and you have that authority
and we're going to approve that aspect
or they may say
we don't like this
then we file a preliminary objection
then the agency has 45 days in order to
uh to fix that situation and
overwhelmingly the agency is able to fix
it in a way that meets the statutory
content
thank you representative are there any
further questions
thank you for your testimony is there
anybody else that wishes to testify i'm
not done but you're shutting me off but
i will fight this because this will not
work thank you representative schmidt
is there anybody else that wishes to
testify that he's not already
i will close the public hearing for
senate bill 358.
all right let's uh
we have
yes we were yes the fire marshal is here
and this time is valuable can we perhaps
do that one
okay we have two bills that we must
execute today
and
thank you and since the fire marshal is
here on senate bill 443
let's take that one up
and we'll resume the fight on 325
after the two early bills
okay representative pearson has a motion
just about gets out
thank you madam chair um i'd like to
make a motion on
443 ought to pass with the amendment i
have to off to introduce an amendment to
is there a second
okay seconded by representative rhodes
and please introduce the amendment
thank you the amendment is 1426
[Music]
h as
was just passed out to you guys
what the amendment does is it adds
similar a similar intent
of language into the duties of the state
fire marshal
along with um
the overall bill which is which handles
the
building code side of things i i think
it's important that if we're going to
have
um some checks and balances within the
building code parts of things we need to
also have those in reference to the fire
code as well
so what the amendment does is it adds
obviously the the part on line 12 that's
in bold
that the local amendments must
be reviewed by the state fire marshal
prior to enforcement
that the fire marshal reviews those
local codes to make sure that they're
actually legitimate
and that
the state fire marshal's office
publishes those along with
the
state fire code this will substantially
help the transparency in the confusion
that builders have and homeowners have
between
various communities because right now
there's not quite one-stop shopping here
and
i think it's ridiculous that an
electrician has to go through a massive
amount of invested investigative work to
figure out what's going to fly in
bedford
and then
go over to seabrook and go oh man okay
there's a local
ordinance we didn't even know about so
this is you know this will
this will help to um
to make that process easier and
also it will make things where they have
since been vetted and
that you don't have a local official
creating code that has not been adopted
by any sort of legislative body
was there a second madam chair
representative rhodes seconded
do you wish to speak to your second
representative pearson covered it okay
uh representative pearson i have a
a small complaint
about this amendment it doesn't include
the
uh requirement that the legislative
history be provided to the building code
board prior to enforcement which was
the subject of the previous amendment
say that again
the amendment that
i drafted and you made this correction
to the fight to the when we were
trying to incorporate the fire code was
primarily done
to have a requirement that the
legislative history of a local building
code change be submitted prior to
enforcement
so there's
it's at the end of section four there
was a
a new clause
and
this doesn't do that
the the one i got from you
in red was just
inserting areas of
of the fire code after the building code
and the fire marshal can speak to why
that he thinks that's problematic
that was very important for the building
code and that's why we started with that
i apologize that it wasn't clear
all right
representative lekkis
thank you so this may be
related but um
in the original bill for the building
code there's various things you know
requiring
um when things need to be provided to
the billing code review board but also
timelines on when they have to respond
what happens
if they don't respond in time
and
[Music]
under what circumstances the municipal
code can be enforced and i don't see
any of that detail in the amendment with
respect to the fire code
uh perhaps we should let the
the fire marshal speak to that
marshall to me
good afternoon sean toomey the state
fire marshal for the record um so i know
we've been working on this the last i
think
almost 24 hours so i apologize if
there's any uh clunkiness to the process
but
the original uh bill that was presented
in the senate had some language on the
fire code and a lot of language on the
building code
and
when we presented
the building code side and the fire code
side
had some complications on the process
and
we all work together to try to come up
with something for some reason the fire
code side fell off altogether and the
building code process got
very specific on timelines and things
like that representative pearson reached
out to me
again yesterday and said you know can we
put the fire code stuff back in and i
said sure what we need to really do is
make sure that uh the reviews would come
to the fire marshal's office and make
sure that it had been properly vetted
through the local legislative process
that it wasn't the intent is though it's
not made up by the local inspector or
the local fire chief um that it doesn't
conflict with the state fire code or
lessen the state fire code and that we
provide a publishing on our website so
that it was available to everyone so
that one of the concerns that we find is
that it's sometimes difficult to find
local amendments um all you know all
over the state so we would have a link
from our website somakodu state fire
code here's the statewide amendments
here's the local amendments and then
they could follow it off
properly
i think that the i just found the the
draft amendment that uh representative
maguire put together uh yesterday uh it
talks about the procedural history of
local adoption relating to relating to
the published notice public hearing and
vote of approval shall be submitted to
the board within 30 days of an enactment
or adoption and prior to enforcement i
have no issue with that being added in
procedurally if you guys
feel necessary to do that i can
definitely support that
one of the things that
the board of fire control
uh
was the original thought was the board
of fire control would hear
the or receive sorry receive the
amendments at the local level on the
fire code issues the problem is that
board meets quarterly and we don't want
to slow down the process for the locals
the building code review board meets
monthly um so the thought is that if it
came directly to the me as the fire
marshal that we could just do a quick
administrative review and keep the
process going that's i guess that's why
we didn't go with the very strict
timelines um as is in the board of fire
control because this was more of
administrative review within the office
i'm happy to answer any questions or
providing more additional information
representative fellows
thank you madam chair um i i can
understand the the purpose for having
you your office review a proposed
amendment so that it doesn't conflict
and all that sort of thing i i do not
understand
the value of having local
um ordinances
on
your website i think it's
it seems to me like a lot of
administrative back and forth
anybody who's going to be doing any kind
of building or renovation
to a property is going to go to the
local
office to get their building permit and
should
not have a problem finding
the appropriate amendments
so
can you respond to that
absolutely thank you so one of the
things that we've learned over the last
couple years is that the design
professionals and the contractors are
having trouble finding that information
so
we have we have the state building code
and the state fire code information on
this department of safety and the state
fire marshal's office website and we
just want to make it easier for the
design professionals and contractors and
anyone for that matter that sort of a
one-stop shop so they can it's it may
simply be a link to the city of
manchester or dover or the town of
um
you know whatever town it happens to be
pittsburgh um you know so that it's just
a it's a it's based on feedback we've
received from the industry in an attempt
to make it a little bit easier
yes it's
the the thing is that
many times the local ordinances are not
quite as easy to find as one would hope
they would be
and the other issue is that
in many cases
the that i've heard the ordinances are
not actually officially adopted
the
inspector just says oh well in in
bedford we do it this way and therefore
you must do it that way or you won't get
your certificate of occupancy
and so by having the
the the
the local amendments
available
the homeowner or whomever can say
to the inspector well
i don't see that requirement in your
local ordinance
and
it'll be more effective to uh to settle
it that way
follow up
so i i'm still having a hard time
understanding why somebody who's going
to do construction
to a building
can't find the local ordinance
and
i'm just concerned about you get
something in two places and they're not
necessarily the same thing anymore
and
i
do you have individuals that complain
that they can't find the local ordinance
or is this something
that you hear only from contractors
i think the concern about it being in
two spots is valid and hopefully we can
work to alleviate as much of that as
possible i'm sure it won't be
perfect um it's we hear it a lot like so
this especially in the smaller
communities that don't have a lot of
them don't have code enforcement better
than roughly 50 percent of the state
um is what we've been told have no
building officials so it's very
difficult for someone to go into the
city hall town hall and ask for for the
information when they don't even have
that official building a court official
doesn't even exist so it's on the
contractor to build it properly um
but there may be some ordinance buried
somewhere
the question is frequent um and it comes
from the contracting world and and the
design professional world it's something
that through some of the study
committees that we've had over the last
couple years trying to improve the code
process we continually hear
that this is a challenge and we're just
trying to figure out a solution to to
minimize the the obstacles i guess for
lack of a better word for the people
trying to develop and build in the state
madam chair can i expand on that just a
little bit yes um representative fellows
if you look at both um lines 28 through
31 in the original bill and
this would be page one my apologies
and also
page 1 28 29 30. so
so those are those are building codes
which is where i
developed
my
my point that this is very convoluted
back and forth and you know i didn't ask
you this question because this says
building code but the notion that first
first you send a a proposed amendment in
for an advisory
you know
evaluation
advisory opinion
and then
assuming they they say it's okay you
have to send it back again
before
before you i don't even know it's so
many back and forth that's the problem
so
there will so as far as as far as the
the publishing and the referencing that
the in particular the fire code that the
city fire marshals would have there
would be no surprises because the local
amendments
their office has to see
so the local community cannot just
would not enact a local ordinance
without them knowing about it
and that would keep
whether they whether they use just
referencing like a hyperlink or whatever
in reference to that or if they
specifically outline it in some manner
there's never there shouldn't be a
situation where a local community
adopted
a local fire code ordinance without them
knowing about it
yes
well they can submit something for for
an advisory opinion they can
they can bring it to the people and the
people might say no or the people might
say yes
so
that's why there is
a two-step process because you want to
make sure that what the people
consider and vote on is technically
accurate
that
right
but the part the part that i'm
i don't like
is the idea that it has to reside with
the state
that's that's the part that that i don't
like the approval i have absolutely i'm
fine with that but that it has to be
stored by the state the other thing i
did and i was nothing to do with fire
codes i didn't look at those i did look
at building codes
so i went to
i had to google it i didn't know it was
under safety but that's where it is and
i can see
the international building codes you
know for buildings for residential
plumbing blah blah blah so i looked at
the residential ones
and as a person
who i'm not going to be doing any like
additions to my property but some people
might
you can see
those building codes you cannot copy and
like paste them they're copyrighted yes
so
i i don't you know if you want to if
if the state wants to do something if
you're going to if you're going to make
them put the ordinances there it ought
to be user friendly which it's not if
you can't you know you got to scroll
down this thing you can't search it you
can't copy and paste it well that's
so okay so i have many several beefs
well that's fine but the
to be honest there are very few
communities in the state that are
actually going to make local ordinances
and changes to the state building code
or the state buyer code
there are very few and it's primarily
going to be the cities
holderness i'm pretty sure does not have
any
town specific ordinances and i know
epsom doesn't
wilderness does not i'm not a hundred
percent sure about plymouth plymouth
mike
representative schmidt
thank you madam chairman uh uh so it was
brought up in a previous meeting of the
committee
and i spoke with mr rancourt
about a statement that was made i
believe by him with regard to the fact
that
certain size towns
cannot make any change to the
to the building code anyway correct
could that be restated for the
committee's benefit in mind
i believe that if a town does not have
code enforcement it cannot make changes
to the state building code is that what
you you said mr reincard yeah which
makes perfect sense exactly it does make
perfect sense and approximately
approximately two thirds important for
everybody to realize that all those
towns are out of the fight so to speak
with regard to making changes
yes and that's why i'm sure that that my
town does not have any local building
code changes so we don't have a code
enforcement officer
the city of dover might well either you
do you do have enforcement i don't know
okay very good
so you so you might have specific
city-specific building code amendments
that you want to
have enforced
what's that
and
and for the benefit of the peop
this is such a small state that that
people
who are located in portsmouth are also
likely to be working in rochester and
dover
and probably manchester and derry as
well
anyway most of the population of this
state is in the bottom 25 miles
above the
the massachusetts border
exactly all right any other comments or
concerns
any questions for the fire marshal while
we're here
all right
um
so i've submitted i've submitted to ols
your request for that
inadvertent
leaving out on the part of page two
section four that's something that's so
the
ols is going to rewrite this amendment
to include that
at the bottom the rest of it will stay
the same that's why we the the
discussion continued so all right so
we'll just have to we'll have to wait
for all this to so you're talking about
they're going to rewrite this with just
like those extra four words at the
bottom of section four yep line
twenty-eight i'm still going to be not
supporting okay thank you i can accept
that
representative goalie
thank you madam chair just one quick
question and i'm not sure whether
this can be done or not where
each amendment deals with
different sections of the bill can we
not adopt
both amendments
without having to have them made into
one
they've got to make one anyway for that
so i just had them just add it to this
so just one stop shopping i guess it's
they gotta they've got it drafted anyway
in some way they would have to come up
with an amendment to do that because i
haven't
i asked for one and then we changed what
we wanted so
um
okay
we're gonna need a different amount
looking in time concerns as to whether
or not they'd have this done quickly or
not and
to move the process i trust that the
representative pearson expressed the
urge i expressed the urgency in in it
yes thank you okay
is there any other discussion or debate
on
this amendment
presuming that we will get the final
amendment with that additional line
representative lepis thank you i'm not
quite sure exactly what that additional
line will be it's at the at the end of
section four
it's line 28 on page two
well 28 just says or adoption but right
you replace the period with a comma and
say and prior to enforcement
oh so the change will be on that section
yes not the amendment
okay no the
the amendment from representative pearce
starts after that
i'm sure they'll figure out a way to
make it as confusing as possible
so so the amendment
this part of the amendment the existing
amendment we're not expecting to change
at all just add to it okay thank you
okay
all right uh let's see
i think procedurally we'll have to
withdraw
14 26.
okay sorry jackie
i trust you've got plenty of forms this
is where this is being coming well i
don't even know
okay fine hang
okay this is the right one okay all
right yes okay
we will post we will postpone this
at least to deal with with the other
bill which
i don't believe has any amendments
325 uh no
138 438 i have an amendment for that
good
senate bill 438
representative sent anastasia you have a
motion
uh yes uh motion in expedient to
legislate for senate bill 438
do i have a second
bracket second by representative lucas
do you wish to speak to your motion
uh sure this is just uh this bill you
know adds protectionism to the law
that's for special interest
as far as uh
you know
uh steel production um
the uh
i guess there's canada subsidizes their
their steel in some way
by uh with electricity or whatever um so
for us to respond to that
by subsidizing our steel with taxpayer
money doesn't seem like an appropriate
solution
representative lackas
thank you and one of the arguments for
this was that there would be some sort
of a
multiplier effect because the money
would be spent locally but
if the money is left with the taxpayers
they're going to spend it somehow as
well which is also going to support
local jobs businesses and whatever so
i don't uh i don't think that's a
terribly effective argument
and um
in general we shouldn't be
doing this sort of thing as my view
thank you
yeah i think that it's appropriate for
itl because
we're essentially giving the industry a
blank check with this bill
that we had no information from anyone
in the state procurement offices or
public works
as to how many contracts are involved
and what kind of a cost impact it might
be expected to be
we're we're
allowing
the total contract to increase by 25
percent
when the steel is maybe 10 percent of
the total contract
if i understand the math correctly
an unscrupulous producer could triple
the cost to the steel
and there'd be no excuse not to accept
that bit
i'm not saying they would but it's
possible that's what the numbers would
work out
and i'm
i don't like the criminal penalties i
don't like the restrictions on capacity
and i don't know what we're getting in
response for this extra money the
the steel producers say they can't
compete on price
but can they compete on quality or
delivery or reliability or something
like that and if so
what kind of a trade-off do we get
we don't know because we don't have any
information on it
representative pearson you had a comment
i do thank you
um
couple things
with this um i i would i'm curious as to
what that representative gross amendment
looks like first of all um secondly
23 states are already doing this
and
my concern
is is that we have effectively now since
the 1970s
pushed
almost all of our industry out of the
united states
it's
you couldn't have dreamed up a more
colossal conundrum than what we've done
and and is a glowing example of this
problem is the fact that the auto
industry has come to a screeching halt
because we don't have anybody that makes
chips in this country anymore my town my
district had hadco a massive circuit
board
manufacturing facility it's gone
so
we have some homeland we have security
implications and a lot of things now
that we have just surrendered to
overseas markets and
where does this stop
i mean we
right now there was there was some
discussion i heard about well you know
the federal government should just put
tariffs on steel they do there are
tariffs on steel at the federal level
until you drill a hole in the steel and
the second you drill a hole in the steel
now it is something that is engineered
and it's literally a loophole
literally a loophole that the chinese
are using to dump
mass quantities of steel right through a
tariff into this country
and i'm just
when you know enough's enough with this
this is we we're we're basically just
destroying our
industries one at a time in this country
and and i'm done with it so
i think that i don't i don't support the
itl
i think if you know an interim study
would be would seem logical here
um in this case but
certainly not an itl i
and like i said i'd like to i'm curious
as to what representative grote's
amendment looks like
representative marshall
uh yes i can't support itl either i
think this bill ought to pass uh i speak
from this personally i grew up in the
steel city in pittsburgh pennsylvania
vice chairman rhodes knows the steel
city uh we
used to have uh blast furnaces and
fabrication plants lining the rivers and
and the surrounding towns were where the
fabrication was done including butler
which was mentioned
near where i grew up uh they also made
railroad cars in in butler to see what's
happened to the blue-collar workers in
that community as industry has left
is is truly sad
they don't have the good jobs that they
used to have
and as representative pearson says
enough is enough we need to be able to
protect our existing industries uh from
really
non-competitive practices uh where their
industry is subsidized in foreign
countries including china so i cannot
support an ideal much
okay representative goalie
thank you madam chair and i too will not
support the itl motion um
i think we all know
american products are quality products
we look at some of the stuff we get from
other countries china
any of the other countries and we look
at it we know right away it's not
american made
i have faith in the american product and
i have faith in the american steel and
i'm gonna support um vote against the
itl so we can have another motion and i
believe there will be an amendment
coming forward removing the 25 percent
which i think will make this an even
better bill to support uh actually
representative goalie if you remove that
limit there is no way that the state
could object to any price for american
steel
regardless
so representative bailey and then
allegro
thank you madam chair
if new hampshire was to impose its own
tariff on canada it would be almost as
if we had declared independence
thank you
actually representative likas did i yet
did i recognize you to speak uh not yet
oh these two of them
sorry and uh
with that last one i think that i have a
problem with my point um
i may come back to it sorry okay we'll
come back to you representative allegro
i can't top that one but i i actually
started off on the other side of this
fence um
i agree with every sentiment of everyone
who's spoken so far
it's true including the most recent
comments
um
but it's also true that
uh we were
i think presented with some hollow
testimony about you know economic
multipliers and things like that as
representative lekkis points out when
money stays in the consumer's pocket and
then is spent locally it has its own
multiplier effect
i can't help but feel that
that this is a job that needs to be done
by way of trade agreements at the
federal level
so um
i would support the itl
but there's also a great deal of merit i
think in the
interim study
model
okay representative blackis
thank you um
regarding the
the assumption of quality american being
better i'm not disagreeing or agreeing
with that but
um i mean that's something that the
procurement people can take into account
i mean
they don't have to take the lowest bid
if it's going to be not meet the quality
requirements
uh just based on costs so i i don't
think that feeds into this thank you
it's not representative
thank you i will be voting against itl
and against interim study should that
motion happen
i think that there are
four
large fabricators in new hampshire
who hire
significant number of people
and those people
work
for those industries in supplying
product to new hampshire
when they can
remove my amendment does remove the 25
percent and i disagree with
representative mcguire in that it makes
the bill ineffective because they can't
compete because there are other reasons
that the that the
state can
there are other exceptions in the bill
that the state can use to exempt
this puts new hampshire
businesses on 11 level playing field and
to think that it's a subsidy
is inaccurate in my estimation
thank you
representative phillips
um yeah just the amendment that you're
talking about are you going to um take
out four all together
did you consider
making 25 well we can't debate the
amendment until we are ready to
right now we're discussing itl
okay
and you can't amend a bill
when you're considering itl
uh represent pearson did you have
another comment i do uh you know i'm
just thinking about you know the tech
what we're doing right now we local
communities in the state of new
hampshire offers tax incentives for for
different industries to come into the
state right now we already do that
so this is really
not
that far off the lines of of some of the
things that the status does to
incentivize
uh you know i can think of in particular
the walmart warehouse and raymond there
was substantial tax breaks that were
given to them for a decade to put that
facility in new hampshire versus another
state so we we kind of already play that
game
um
in in a slightly different way the other
thing too just thinking about is a hot
rod guy the auto industry and i mean i
appreciate the fact that the japanese
automakers have put plants in tennessee
and the carolinas and all that but at
the end of the day the final ultimate
profit buck still goes back to japan
so
i'm
very concerned again about
the manufacturing
and
the various industries that we are just
forcing out and steel
steel as in a specific example here is
something we use to build the navy so
i know that's more of a
outside the necessarily the borders of
new hampshire but
just as a general rule this is this is a
road we've been going down way too long
representative schmidt
so i won't be supporting the itl motion
because
i think
the answer to a number of the questions
that have been raised is to interim
study the bill so that we get those
questions answered
i don't like the idea
tariffs for one thing that were
mentioned
who pays the tariffs it's not the
foreign countries that pay the tariffs
it's the american consumers who pay the
tariffs so that was a a
convenient misrepresentation by a
certain former
person
with regard to tariffs being the answer
the answer is we don't know
enough about the totality of this this
is not the commerce committee where we
deal with such issues on a regular basis
and i think we should definitely not go
itl because it's kind of a slap in the
face at the very least that we have
questions that we don't even
get answered before we make a final
decision
representing broda
i also want to remind the committee that
this is going to finance and since this
is a state
issue they can decide whether or not the
state can afford it
and lastly had other
believe me as we've never seen in other
hearings had departments involved with
the state been interested in this they
would have testified so we didn't hear
from them and that that
silence is telling thank you
yeah i will say that i did reach out to
the
administrative services in their
procurement department
and the person i spoke to said yes well
we buy steel but at a grand total of
six or seven hundred thousand dollars a
year
so it wouldn't fall under the purview of
the spill and i have been unable to
reach the people in transportation or
public works that would be making larger
contracts
representative fellows um yes that that
was one of my thoughts that that
the state of new hampshire rarely build
builds a whole building that would
require this amount of steel but we do
have coming up
um hopefully a new parking garage which
i assume will have lots of steel in it i
certainly hope so
and and so then that kind of makes me
wonder about the effective date because
this is effective january
well that's probably good we could if we
passed this we could
hopefully be saying that we want our
parking garage built with american steel
because i don't think they'd start
before then but i don't know that would
be interesting to know thank you
anyone else represent judy yes thank you
madam
uh i don't like to
i don't want to support itl
the reason why because i don't want to
close
the business doors here in new hampshire
because uh
what we are doing here
in america i would like to say to see it
stay in america
because i remember one of uh the owner
they were talking about um
overseas
they are the one who making money
on top of us so i i cannot support itl
because i don't want uh
those owners to close their doors
thank you
representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman so there was
some discussion about
well in canada they they pay the light
bills for the businesses and they pay
the health insurance for the employees
and etc etc etc
and that is the exact reason why i
actually want to support this bill is
because the businesses that are here do
have to pay their electric bills
and
because we are fantastic
you know it's kind of a double-edged
sword for the for the employers but yes
they do have to pay health insurance if
they have people who work over a certain
amount of hours
and it the it has to stop somewhere and
we have to also start somewhere we have
to start getting this back
and i didn't realize until
representative pearson told me he told
us i don't know how many states are
already
doing such things
but it's it's a rippling effect and i
i just think good conscious cannot sit
here and say
and and say no i i i just can't do that
and i
i just think i need the record to say
that i can't
yes represent pearson thank you um i sit
on the state procurement commission
and we've never specifically addressed
steel but i will note that one of the
sponsors of this bill senator carson is
the chairman of the state procurement
commission
yes
yes well
my concern is that as the people who
testified
told us in the hallway after the hearing
that there's a policy decision here on
how much more we want to pay for steel
to support their businesses
and
clearly it was the people whose
businesses would benefit from this bill
that showed up to testify they were all
people in the iron business who expected
to get contracts that would be
that they so that they would be able to
deal with
with uh
cheaper foreign
competition
and those are the people who showed up
we don't
and we're asking the taxpayers to come
up with more money we don't know how
much
to
place business with these
these companies rather than others
or to tilt the playing field towards
them so that they can get more contracts
and i'm
opposed to that and i'm
very very strongly opposed to doing we
don't know how much money is involved
i'm trying to have a question in
reference to the
restrictions in the spill yes the i
the the the four or five entities that
came
to us that are exist in the state of new
hampshire i would presume would all be
bidding on these jobs but this doesn't
really force it
to be in new hampshire only right this
it could be a firm from mass or maine or
mass domain or uh
or from
chicago or right so so so there will not
be a lack of of bidders
to these jobs this is not funneling into
a
single entity monopoly there there are
there will still be the bidding process
and all that right
yes
yes version of like us
um thank you as uh
you know as mentioned the only people uh
testifying were uh in the people in the
business and supporting it and it's the
classic problem of concentrated benefits
and diffuse costs um
there are you know a limited number of
uh
businesses that would uh benefit from
this uh we just heard from the ones in
new hampshire but there you know there's
going to be some one was from
massachusetts ah okay thank you
um
but the people that are going to be
paying the price are
the the uh you know individual taxpayers
and
i mean for the most part they're
probably not aware of this at all
and the amount each would be affected
would be small enough that it doesn't
make
sense for them to come in and testify
you know against it but it does add up
across um all of them
so i think you know as the
representatives of those taxpayers i i
see it as my job
to represent them and protect them in
situations like this thank you
i think that the new hampshire residents
would be rather surprised to find
that the things that are built in new
hampshire using
is not using
first of all new hampshire
providers and second of all american
steel i think that is the
misunderstanding
that excuse me that people have in new
hampshire and i think taxpayers
are should be
would need to know that
and i can't believe that anyone in this
room is going to think that
costs of things are going to skyrocket
because we're
passing this bill we don't know but
we're speculating there's going to be a
large amount and i think that's
um
an inappropriate
comment to make
representatives um
this is mostly a question i think but we
keep talking about american steel but
this the source of steel is not
local it's not american
it's only the manufacturing right the
reshaping of it this bill specifies that
the steel in question
be smelted and made in america
it does it doesn't say in new hampshire
because there are no smelters in new
hampshire okay that's that's my
follow-up yeah if i had made a follow-up
then
i i would feel uneasy giving since we
don't mention new hampshire here i'm not
sure we're benefiting new hampshire
company necessarily companies
because they could come from elsewhere
chicago anywhere
um
so maybe that's the correction that
needs to be made at least so thank you
representative marsh
yes i want to share that i pressed the
people who testified pretty hard as to
the source of their raw material we
finally got some answers that they're
mostly using smelters where they don't
have recycled steel they're using
smelters from down south such as alabama
so that was the source of the steel
thank you for that information
any other comments or discussion
yes representative thank you madam chair
so
in regards to the
you know asking the taxpayers to you
know to come up with with more money
i i believe every single day there's
somebody whether it's at a local
select board meeting it's a school board
meeting or here in the legislator of the
senate that
somebody is asking the taxpayers come up
with some more money for something
whether it's you know it's
it's necessarily a pet project or
something to this scale but every single
day we're asking people to come up with
with money that we all are not going to
necessarily agree with but i do know
personally when i go to the store and i
see something that's marked made from
china or marked from usa even if i'm
paying
20 cents more a dollar more i i
personally tend to to buy that so again
i'm just going to stick with my
it has to stop and start
someplace
representative bailey
i i would just sort of comment that a
choice of that is your personal choice
whereas here we're deciding what the
taxpayers will pay for a price what
price they will pay and i don't think
that is our personal choice
represent lonzara
thank you madam chair
i think the topic is a double edged
steel so
i'm basically um i can see both sides
um
and uh but i will be voting against the
itl
okay
anyone else
in that case the motion is inexperienced
legislate on senate bill 438
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes no
representative piantamonte
representative
thank you representative pearson no
yakubovic no
representative lucas yes
representative allegro
no
representative bailey
yes
i'm sorry hang on a minute i did that
wrong
representative santo
yes
representative goalie
no
representative schuett
representative gertie
no madam
representative schmidt no
representative fellows
no
oops representative marsh no
representative fontenot no
jackie i mean representative grotevo to
know
representative o'brien
no
and the chair yes
so it is four to fifteen
one more
oh
oh i am so sorry representative lanzara
no
thanks no
oh i am so sorry
so that's three
i made a mistake three four four to
sixteen
four to six no it can't be
please out of the numbers there were i
heard four names saying
yes
i heard okay these are the people that i
have as yes
representative mcguire representative
lucas and representative bailey and
representative santana
uh that's how i got mixed up
okay four it's four to
fifteen
okay
fine
excuse me for that's fine we're
we like to make sure our numbers are
correct
representative pearson you have a motion
the itl motion failed
oh i'm sorry i was about to make a
motion if i may
but before i'll i'll know i'll exceed to
uh representative pearson i'm dying to
hear what you have to say
um the idea of interim study was floated
and i think that's a reasonable
alternative
so i'd like to move it to interim study
okay representative allegro moves
interim study is there a second
representative schmidt
okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
i think the last 25 minutes of
discussion spoke to it um
and it was brought up and it's a
reasonable um
motion i think and we need to know more
about this and consider it more deeply i
think
representative schmidt you wish amen
okay representative marsh you wish to
speak
uh yes i don't support interim study
either i've for my entire lifetime watch
the death of the steel industry in my
hometown
i can't support doing nothing on this
issue so i will oppose this motion
thank you any anyone else representing
bowling
thank you madam chair and i too will
oppose the interim study i think the
time to act is now
and
it's time to buy american thank you
anyone else
okay the motion is interim study by
representative allegro seconded by
representative schmidt the clerk can
call the role
representative rhodes
yes
representative pierre dimanto
representative pearson
i'm gonna go now
representative yakubovic yes
representative lucas yes
representative ellie grow yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lonzara no
representative santo nostazo yes
representative goalie
no
representative schuett
no representative joji no madam
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh
no
representative fellows no representative
fontener
no
the clerk votes no
representative o'brien no bend the chair
yes
9 to 10
motion fails
i would like to um
offer to house bills 3 i mean sorry 438
amendment
1422. and i will circulate it to the
committee it removes the
sub paragraph 4 referring to the 25
percent
thank you representative marsh
question
yes uh so we're introducing an amendment
but we're not voting on anything
yet correct except to attach the
amendment
correct correct the motion is ought to
they're coming around
the amount the promotion was ought to
pass and she presented the amendment
and we will vote on the amendment prior
to ought to pass okay let me get a piece
of i
i think representative bailey could you
please
okay he's gonna i made 25 copies
speedmonty do you need a copy of the day
this should be one of them
oh thank you
um thank you madam chair
house bill
1422 removes the subparagraph referring
to the 20 percent
25 percent increasing
the allowable increase in cost as an
exception
to
a waiver
from um
purchasing
and this was
as discussed during the itl motion
concern to many people because they felt
that
it would add padding
to the
um
quotes
and therefore i remove that
and um there and should other
should the um
department of the the das find
they can also find a waiver upon being
inconsistent with public service public
interest which could refer to the cost
and also is not produced and fabricated
in the united states and insufficient
those would be the two
and also it's not fabricated that
would be in public interest so the
public interest is part is still part of
this
bill and therefore
could include cost as a public interest
if the
price is out of line with what the
community can afford
that's a very long explanation i
apologize
representative marsh do you wish to
speak to your second uh yes i want to
say that putting into statute a uh
bidding process where up to a 25
uh premium is allowed is the practical
guarantee that you'll get 24 and a half
percent uh bids on your contract so that
should not go into statute and i agree
entirely with the representative grota
that the first uh
point that application the project would
be inconsistent with the public interest
uh gives them plenty of leeway to uh put
through waivers when necessary
representative laccas
um
i mean i understand that the argument
about not putting 25 in because it would
attract such bids but
[Music]
public interest is pretty fuzzy and
since we're already indicating that
we're willing to provide subsidies
i mean the question is that at what
what's the threshold for the das to uh
to claim it's inconsistent with the
public interest you could argue any
um bump in price is inconsistent with
the public interest and given that we
we removed it i'm not sure
under what circumstances they would be
able to claim that i'm not comfortable
with this
representative pearson and then fellows
if i because i'm truly trying to digest
what the removal of
four means to me it looks like it it
makes
the
it gives the department of
administrative services now a greater
ability to waive this
because you know you had a you had this
25 more criteria well that's essentially
gone away so now we've
this would give the department
administrative services
greater flexibility
to not follow this so
i don't i don't think this makes
makes it more difficult i think it makes
it easier for the state to
to say now we're going with something
else
thank you representative phillips
um thank you madam chair um actually if
i were going to
make an amendment i would take the 25
and make it lower but
um that's aside for now and
i would just respond to representative
leckus
that if you look on line 18
it says so assume assume that the 25
comes out
it says in granting a waiver the
department shall consider all
appropriate factors including
any cost
so they but they'll have to explain why
they did it so they'll they can say
you know the cost is you know
100 000
higher
and um
that's why we're going to grant a waiver
and go with foreign steel but they have
to say why that makes them say why
okay anyone else
i agree with representative fellows that
if you're going to that the more
appropriate thing to do would be to save
steel as a small part of these contracts
therefore it should only increase the
total cost by
two percent or something like that
but
but uh that's not what we're discussing
anyone else have a comment
all right the motion is to adopt
amendment
1422 h
click and call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
representative pierre de monte yes
representative pearson yes
representative jakob
no
representative lucas no representative
allegro no representative bailey no
representative lunzara yes
representative santo nostalzo
no
representative goalie
yes
uh-oh
i'm sorry
can we please start over i think i think
i'm right but i just i don't know why
this is so dif was the first time i've
ever done this and i apologize
okay
representative rhodes i have yes
representative pia de monte i have yes
representative pearson i have yes oh i
think this is okay representative
jacobovic i have no representative lucas
i have no representative allegro i have
no representative bailey i have no
representative lonzara i have yes
representative santon estazo i have no
representative goalie i have yes
okay representative schuett
yes representative georgie
representative schmidt
okay
representative marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative faulkner
yes
i vote yes
representative o'brien yes
okay one two three
no oh
i am so sorry represent than the chair
votes no
okay so i have one and i have one two
three four five so i have six no's
one two three four five
and i have 12 yeses so the uh the bill
the amendment is adopted and
representative grota you move ought to
pass with amendment yes i do i moved
otpa and is it that seconded
yes okay
vibration growth is seconded by
representative marsh
do we need any further discussion
i think we've beaten it to death i tend
to agree all right in that case not
seeing any uh hands
the motion is ought to pass with
amendment and the clerk can call the
rule
okay
let me see representative rhodes yes
representative pierre de monte
yes
representative pearson yes
representative yakubovic no
representative lucas no
representative allegro
yes
representative bailey
no
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nostazo no
representative goalie
yes representative schuett yes
representative gertie
representative schmidt
is left is not here okay representative
marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative faulkner yes
representative grotto votes yes
representative o'brien yes okay
and the chair
now
so it is 13 yes
five nays and one no vote so the bill
passes otpa
fine i don't think this should go on
consent
okay
is someone going to write a minority
report if tony doesn't mind i'd like to
write the minority report okay
representative santana will write a
minority report
the recommendation from you will be itl
correct
okay okay
okay i'm gonna noodle all this out after
all right
do you what's that one do we have your
amendment representative uh no no
okay
well if we don't have the amendment for
house bill 433
let's move back to our debate on
senate bill 325
where we had been
which had an octopass motion by
representative pearson second by
representative schuett
325 local uh
all right give everyone a moment to
remember representative schuett
thank you um i just wanted to make the
comment that uh
this committee and in fact the full
house
voted last year in favor of house bill
356 i believe it was
that
recognized public works employees
as part of the first responder team in
certain circumstances for the fact of
granting them death benefits if they're
killed in one of those circumstances
so i i think
that certainly shows the argument that
public works employees who are on the
scene of emergencies
should qualify well i'd like to comment
that there doesn't appear to be
much
discrepancy with including or
much difficulty to anyone with including
public works employees it's the whole
long list of other
people that are not normally considered
first responders
representative fellows
so i'm not sure that i got it right but
i tried to look up in the rsas
and under homeland security
to see what this would impact because
this is just a definition
of first responders and and i could it i
only came up it only found one word one
place
where it said first responder
which didn't have anything really didn't
have any impact at all
so
okay
uh representative allegro and then lakas
and then chew it again
yeah i too tried to look up the
definition of first responders and i
found it in about a half a dozen regular
dictionaries
and uh words do have meaning
and also in a department of labor
document
and i saw definitions like
a person such as a police officer or emt
who was among those responsible for
going immediately to the scene of an
accident or emergency blah blah blah a
person employed in the public sector emt
firefighter police volunteer ems
a police officer firefighter emt a
military related website said they're
the first to arrive and help at
emergency scenes
uh department of labor uh lists um
a bunch of criteria and and detectives
deputy sheriff so they're a little bit
more expansive police officers
highway patrol officers and so on they
include those definitions
those
positions under first responders
i think that we could go on
expanding and expanding and expanding
and we're just changing the meaning of
the english in the english language
and
at the moment it may not have
implications
for
benefits and insurance and all kinds of
stuff like that but
you know clearly if the department of
labor is defining it
well
all of those implications are to be
included at some point
representative lackas
thank you um
i think you heard earlier i may not have
the words exactly right but basically
it's a symbolic or recognizing and
i mean i don't
have any huge concerns about this but i
don't really see any serious value in it
and so i intend to vote against the otp
just on that thank you
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
i would further point out that
during the pandemic we heard about
ambulances lined up
bringing patients
who in fact many of whom were dying
of covid
to emergency rooms and the nurses
doctors
people at the hospitals who were
receiving those patients
i would say we're acting under emergency
conditions
as first responder
and
anyone else we're all back up to speed
on this one
okay
uh in that case the motion is ought to
pass by representative pearson
and the clerk call the roll
representative rhodes yes representative
pierre de monte
yes representative pearson yes
representative jacobovich
yes
representative lucas no representative
allegro no
representative bailey
no
representative lonzara
yes
representative santo nostazo no
representative goalie
yes representative stewart
yes representative gertie
madame
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative
yes
i vote yes representative o'brien yes
the vote is oh in the chair i bet you
what would you like
i don't know i haven't decided on this
one
[Music]
we meant house rules so that the clerks
get a little shock collar maybe for the
chairs to remind them
actually just just re redo the sheet so
that they say so that i'm at the bottom
but in this case i think i will vote yes
for this symbolic bill okay
the vote is 1524
all right
uh representative pearson i will expect
your
committee report at your very earliest
convenience
yes ma'am is there going to be a
minority report
all right representative allegro i've
taken your recommendation will be itl
okay
so this is so bad man i'm sure i have a
procedural question in reference to
fixing our problem here with this other
bill
you you filed amendment that is still
that deals with part four my amendment
deals with part five could we not as a
committee adopt both amendments and then
ols do we have both of them well yours
exists and mine exists because you
emailed us yours oh so they do both
exist
yes absolutely okay so then that'll take
care of that
it being a deadline
okay so 325 is not all consent correct
the 15 to 40 no no
all right so
okay so which one okay which amendment
do we do we want to adopt you we had
started with the amendment for we should
finish your amendment since
is being delayed
yeah we're not going to need ols at this
point okay
we are through with senate bill 325
and we still have senate bill
358 443 440 433
443 god i should not be doing my taxes
tonight that's for sure
that's true
okay so we are
considering the amendment from
representative pearson yes it was and
due to
technical difficulties we will then
consider my amendment
correct
okay yep so
yeah since both of these amendments deal
with a different part they'll
we've confirmed with um
house staff about this
no it is 1426 that's the uh
the first amendment is
amendment 1426 h which representative
pearson passed around earlier deals with
section five
yep okay
so we we did have discussion with this
the state fire marshal has weighed in on
on his concerns
um
or not his concerns how how this makes
the world better for him
and
uh in his office
and uh we did hear from representative
fellows and as to her concerns as well
that's kind of the score you know the
okay if you're keeping score that's kind
of where we are
yes back to the i think it's the third
inning on this one
so is does anyone else wish to comment
on this amendment representative fellows
just to add to what i previously said
that i think it's like way too much
bureaucracy and a burden on the the um
local communities also i would like to
point out that on the fiscal note that
there's a cost of 72 000
to do this because somebody wants a
position
yes the cost is within the department of
safety
and the building control board to
oversee this
i'd like can i add to this
representative pearson thank you madam
chair um also in discussions with the
state fire marshal
as some of you may or may not be aware
the state agencies go through a period
of uh review i'm gonna butcher this but
tech review will call it to update your
websites and you guys seem to be kind of
near the on deck circle right now anyway
so what a what a great time to to make a
couple of changes to their website when
they're already up for
an overhaul through the normal
scheduling process of
of this so
convenient it might cost less than the
decision
amazingly timely
one never knows does one representative
like us
thank you actually my concern is that
the process may be a little too simple
but um
there is a more detailed process laid
out for building codes i would have
preferred a similar process here for the
fire codes but
given the circumstances i will uh i will
support this
yeah
i'd like to comment there are probably
far fewer amendments to the building to
the fire code than the building codes
which would make it less
less critical that we specify the
detailed process
because i mean i've i've actually never
heard of it anyone talking about an
amendment to the fire code
and that's part of where this problem
lies is that they're the the actual
appropriate procedure
locally to go through a your local
legislative process of formally adopting
seems to not really occur
and
well no wonder we don't know about them
this and because of that we have
rogue bureaucrats in essence creating
things that don't really exist so
you know you can't just make this stuff
up on the fly anymore that's never been
okay and it certainly should not be okay
moving forward representative blackis
thank you that's actually why i'm uh
even though with some concern i'm
willing to support it because uh
ad hoc rules are are not legitimate and
i'd like to see that change thank you
okay
any other comments
all right the motion is to adopt
amendment 1426
to senate bill 443
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes representative
pierre de monte yes
representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative lucas yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes representative santo nostal
yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative
giudi
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes representative faulkner yes
the clerk votes yes representative
o'brien yes and the chair
yes yay
19-0 all right we have an amendment
recommended
and do you have the number of that
amendment yes
yes
okay representative goldie moves
amendment uh
yep
that will be amendment 2022-1388h
all right and i'll second that
she sent it to you by email
sorry okay so just a moment um who made
that motion i'm sorry representative
goalie made that motion because he had
the number and i seconded it okay thank
you
represent goalie do you wish to speak to
your motion
thank you madam chair and
um
i just pulled it up briefly and correct
me if i'm wrong the only change i see is
adding at the end of
uh on page two of the bill line 28 where
it says or adoption
uh the words and prior to enforcement
are added that is the only change to
that section that was
the
recommendation of both the building
control board and the industry people
who were testifying to
to to the bill and what it does is it
ensures
that after the technical review
the actual
um
the board knows that the amendment has
been properly adopted by the local
jurisdiction before it's enforced
any other comments
discussion
okay
seeing none
the motion is to adopt amendment 1388
to senate bill 443 in addition to 1426.
and the clerk can call a roll
representative rhodes yes representative
peter monte yes
representative pearson yes
representative jacob
yes representative lucas yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes representative center
nostalgia yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative
madame
schmidt yes representative marsh
yes representative fellows yes
representative faulkner yes
representative grota votes yes
representative o'brien yes
19 to zero
oh in the chair i would say yes you go
ahead okay
yes the amendment is adopted 19-0
representative pearson
okay so that's going to put us in i'm
going to move autopass with
the following two amendments 1388h
and 1426 each
second
representative goalie seconds okay
with both amendments
right i just i just sent them an email
to tell them to disregard their own set
that's right yeah i said i think they
were all shut down yeah we get that
figured out thank you though yes we will
need we will need the final amendment
before it goes into the calendar but
they've got 24 hours on that
representative uh pearson do you wish to
speak to your motion thank you madam
chair the um aside from the the two
little tweaks that we did you know we've
we've uh
we heard from the the players in this
game and
we have a long a long history of some
frustrations with with how things have
gone in the past and this
will
smooth some of that out so
um
i think that this is this is going to
work
and i think this is going to work not
only just for the contractors because we
don't certainly just represent them but
i think it's going to work for joe
homeowner too so
i'm certainly in favor of this
this change and uh
in
tightening up what we're doing
representing goldie
thank you madam chair i think this is a
big step forward in the codes and i
think there's going to be a lot of
people out there that are going to
appreciate this change
yes
thank you um
i'd like to comment that this was a
recommendation of the study committee on
building codes
and
keeping track of the municipal
amendments
has always been a hassle
and
this is this does not require any
municipality to go back
and re-adopt its current amendments nor
to send any of its current amendments
the building code review board
however with the state building code
changing it's likely that many of them
will do so anyway
but so this is very timely in that
regard
and i hope you support it
anyone else
no representative schmidt is not saying
anything
in that case the motion is ought to pass
with amendments
and the clerk can call the rule
representative rhodes yes representative
pierre demonte yes representative
pearson yes representative
yes representative lucas yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzarra yes
representative santo
yes
representative goalie yes representative
yes representative jody
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows no
representative faulkner yes
representative votes yes representative
o'brien
yes and the chair yes
it's 18 to 1.
okay
the devotion passes 18 to 1 or does
anyone object to consent no
okay we will put this one on consent
and the
report is
due no later than tomorrow
okay and
while we're on a roll i would like to
make a motion
on senate bill 230 which was the
practice of body art
and i would like to i would move interim
study because we're already looking at
another bill regarding
new licensure for establishments that
one's on the licensure of massage
establishments
and i think that we we need to
look at them
together because the issues are very
much the same
okay
okay so representative lekis got there
first
all right
representative likes do you wish to
speak to it
interim study
on senate bill 230.
uh no you covered it thank you
okay
any uh
give everyone a motion to shuffle their
papers and then we'll see if anyone has
a comment
yep
any comments or discussion
representative fontenot
thank you madam chair um question first
the
the bill regarding
massage is that currently in interim
study it is it was a house bill it's an
interim study
and we plan to look at it because
when we were working on it in
subcommittee one suggestion was that the
um
we should just give
oplc
you know inspection authority to just
just to verify license status
but
when we asked them for some language to
do so they came up with a
a lot of bureaucracy and rather
expensive as well
and since the problems are
concentrated in the cities and the
larger towns
it
requiring statewide licensure of the
establishments
needs to be looked at very hard
thank you
anyone that's right you weren't there
when we were discussing that
any other comments questions concerns
okay
in that case the motion is interim study
on senate bill 230 and the clerk can
call the role
representative rhodes yes representative
scitec
i mean representative piedemante yes
oh my gosh representative pearson
yes representative jacobovic
representative lucas
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzara yes
representative center nostal yes
representative goalie yes representative
stewart yes representative george we
made them represent schmidt
he's not here
okay representative marsh yes
brilliant fellows yes representative yes
representative groeder votes yes
representative o'brien yes in the chair
yes
okay it's 18
does anyone object to
consent seeing none okay that will go on
consent
18-0
representative schmidt was out of the
room while the question was called
okay
so here are the ones that we have in
passed this one's going to uh
subcommittee this one's going to sub
committee what about hospital 330 where
is that
well this is the one middle three-third
and we need an amendment representative
forehand amendments does anyone else
have another bill yes i think is ready
for
for exactly yes i do i'd like to pay i'd
like to make a motion to ought to pass
on senate bill 357
second madam chair
senate bill 357 please remind us of the
topic mental health training for first
responders
she already did
a second representative do you should
speak to your motion
yes i would
uh as as i mentioned
previously in my testimony i sit on the
ptsd commission and the commission is
the
author of this
um having been filed by senator birdsell
this
continues the commission this is not one
of those derelict commissions that exist
on paper that the speaker has to figure
out somebody to sit on this commission
is
quite active it does meet monthly
and its work is ongoing
as we discussed earlier the the simple
changing of the date wouldn't quite work
because the
when you write a bill for a commission
the bills indicate what the purpose and
scope of the commission is and
that
as as an ongoing commission is a little
bit fluid and and has tweaked a little
bit so that the language can just kind
of stay where it is
the biggest thing here
with this is
um
actually hold on one second
this is not early right i don't i have
an amendment i need to draft to this so
i'm gonna i gotta withdraw that motion
because i'm not as i'm as i'm looking at
you what about the dispatchers and
making clear that it does not work so i
did something brilliant and i have two
copies of the same bill and made notes
on both of them and didn't combine them
together so
i trust they will be the final result
congratulations
pearson
all right so yeah we're gonna i gotta i
gotta write a quick amendment on this so
i'm gonna withdraw sorry all right we
that motion is withdrawn
that sound effect is amazing
oh i didn't realize that
[Laughter]
anyone else have one that they think is
ready um i have a question of the chair
yeah the amendment that i have on 3 30
do you feel that's non-germane
or
sort of jermaine it's
no now the uh she wants to add an
oversight committee to senate bill 330
yeah and we're altering the do you have
enough number
yes i have uh okay
we will uh
we'll add a hearing for it
yeah
the oplc oversight yeah
yeah this is this is something that we
interesting
senate bill 330 has a study committee on
oplc
and
some of it's germain is some of it is
not so
i'm sure i believe there was also some
discussion as to
an amendment perhaps in reference to
senate bill 330 pulling these this
entire boxing and wrestling commission
out of the oplc
okay so it sounds like we're not quite
ready
to exact that unless
unless you wanted to discuss it
i don't have a message
no okay so it's not ready uh somewhere
that's the
the thing is that the for the the first
part which is the amendment
on
revising the the study committee is
perfectly germane right the second
oversight committee
is that this in the field here what's
that
all right
i'm not sure if yeah this is
um
it seems germane to me because this is a
bill about overs about the operation
of the oplc
and already includes a
an oversight it already includes a study
committee on the operations
certainly on topic
no it doesn't
i just
yeah
i just thought as a commission i mean
it's a committee we felt uncomfortable
at least i do of putting boxing and
wrestling under oplc because they don't
issue any licenses for that and i think
we should look at it i think it's better
suited under the lottery group
rather than oplc and i
i don't
this amendment is fine other than that i
think it's important that we take that
out of oplc i just don't it has no place
in there i don't think
i'm
i'm not following sorry i was
concentrating on something oh that's
okay representative stuart i just want i
just mentioned that your
amendment keeps the boxing and wrestling
commission in oplc
um i did discuss that with the chair and
uh she felt that
we could make that deletion if we chose
to that's correct uh
so yeah that's independent that's fine
okay
yeah i don't i don't have a problem with
that um
listen
dude
do you want to talk about what what the
amendment yeah that's uh
representative goalie you have a comment
or
no i was just gonna question if we were
just discussing the amendment right now
um obviously this is not ready for
an exec session because of the original
bill that needed boxing commission
removed out of it but i was just
questioning where we are and where we're
at
well at the moment we
well we're discussing this this
amendment i am
i wouldn't want it to be declared
non-germane if we don't hold a hearing
on it
so i want to confirm that before we
accept it okay
but we could
take take a look at it since we're here
and we also want to
take a straw poll on whether or not we
want to
take out moving the boxing and rex
wrestling commission because that's a
separation yes representative schmidt
so who is driving this
uh move to put the boxing commission
to in oplc as opposed to where it is now
that's a very good question we don't we
have two problems yes the first problem
is that the committee on legislative
administration
deleted the the administrative
attachment of the boxing and wrestling
commission
to
the secretary of state
so that at the moment they don't report
it they're not attached to anybody
i'm fine with pulling it out because i
think
even though it definitely is kind of an
odd duck i think you could make an
argument for it but there's certainly
some opposition and it
it's been working this way is there a
problem with it being under the
secretary of state
i don't know if there's a problem or not
but when i
i was sitting in on senate edna as
we typically do with house bills just in
case they need introduction
and this was introduced in senate edna
and i'm looking at the
colleague that was sitting next to me
going we we never heard i've never heard
of this how did and it really should
have
i guess it probably should have come to
us but it went to legend admin that's
why
that's why none of us have any idea that
that even happened
so
they
somebody thought that it needed to be
removed out of the secretary of state's
office but they didn't put it anywhere
it's just floating if that if that bill
makes it through the senate it's a it's
a board that exists that reports i guess
in theory to no one
so
it's a governor i guess it's but it you
know as an executive function but
this
this this piece of legislation says now
okay now we're going to put it over in
oplc i don't know why that didn't go
through the other bill but clearly the
senate and the house were not
communicating with each other in
reference to this
all of a sudden massive interest in the
boxing and wrestling commission
so i you know i just i don't think it's
appropriate to go under oplc
at all i think
if you look at what some of the other
states do especially in nevada that
falls under their lottery gaming
commission or whatever it's a big deal
in nevada you know a big
deal they have all kinds of events like
that we have very relatively few right
well it does need to go somewhere i
didn't they didn't need to go someplace
but if it's with the secretary of state
and it's not really causing a problem
why don't we just leave it right there
well because we've lost control of that
that animal is already in the senate oh
that's already passed the house on
consent
yeah the thing of it is the boxing and
wrestling commission doesn't have much
interaction
interaction with other parts of the
state government
they run their own operations they
they
uh
license the uh
the umpires and things like that and
basically to a per a live person that
can give them a twenty dollar bill
and they provide a noticeable
a surplus to which goes into the general
fund they're
not really
something that would be appropriate in
the
oplc
um
lottery would be okay if we wanted to
put him there or back to the secretary
of state is fine as far as i'm concerned
like you say there hasn't i have not
heard of any problems
representative lackas
yeah um yeah i don't think it belongs
under oplc i mean we could just if it's
not going to cause a serious problem to
just let it float somewhere under the
governor if they pretty much run on
their own i don't know that there's a
problem with that i'd be okay with that
or if somebody get an amendment to put
it under lottery whatever but it's not
oplc
my only concern is to look on the
lottery commissioner's face when this
goes through and they go what did we
just inherit because as of right now
they have no idea we're even talking
about this right
is there some
serious problem caused by
taking it not putting it no or
taking not putting an oplc let it float
and deal with something next year after
talking the laundry room i can tell
representative schuett lingoli
thank you madam chair um i would be
happy if the committee chooses to remove
that
to have
this amendment redrafted
removing that and then that would allow
you time to
schedule a
non-jermaine amendment hearing if
necessary next time we meet
okay represent goalie
thank you madam chair
the more i look at this the more i see
why it shouldn't be going where it's
going i mean when you
when you look at the commission through
the office of professional licensure and
certification shall collect five percent
of gross receipts that is totally out of
line on what the oplc does they
shouldn't be collecting money for
organizations to be transferred into
their fund that's one of them one big
reason why i will not support this we
could always attach it to dra since
[Laughter]
anyway yeah
representative shute if you're going to
redraft it you might want to put a
separate effective date for this
oversight committee
the
if you're going to redraft your
amendment to do that
you should have an effective date for
the oversight committee being after the
election
um
it may be just check very carefully
okay so
uh shall the the question before us is
shall we tell representative schuett to
have the boxing and wrestling commission
removed from senate bill 330.
all right
let's go buy a show of hands yes madam
chair
yes okay anyone opposed
representative judy it's not unanimous
but if you would look on the back page
representative o'brien are you in favor
of moving the boxing and wrestling
commission to oplc
yes you are
you mean
okay
that's uh 17 to two so i think we'll
have you work on the amendment that way
and i will be able to the effective date
is on the very back flip it over
it one page is stapled the wrong way
around
thank you that's really and there's a
sunset date um also
i will confirm whether or not it's a
non-jermaine amendment and we will
consider that amendment and vote on the
bill sometime else
all right
anybody else have anything that needs
discussion from the whole committee
representative uh i just suggest that a
number of us including myself get more
sleep
given the evidence
ah well we can try that
uh before we go representative rhodes
has a motion on oh who's gonna write the
blurb
on senate bill 277
which to refresh your memory is to
extend the temporary
um
temporary and emergencary licenses for
two years at a cost of i think seven
hundred thousand dollars
sorry about that good that's good all
right i think
each committee has one bill
and
we will
thank you for getting through the early
bills
and we we will vote on the others as we
get the chance
good night
you